last night we talked a little bit about
this there's a poll that was produced by
the southern poverty law center and
another organization they teamed up on
it
in it they find that young men of both
political parties think feminism has
done more harm than good
and that's fascinating i also thought it
was interesting that this this
study survey comes out around the same
time as the daily wires what is a woman
where we're basically learning that a
lot of these ideas are becoming
extremely unpopular even among young
democrats so today
we're going to talk a whole lot about
modern feminism where it's at why young
men feel this way we're going to talk
about the ideas presented in what is a
woman from the daily wire we've got the
top psychologists talking about how half
of their patients are trans kids and
we'll explore modern feminism and why
people are so angry about it and i want
to talk about families because we've got
this article talking about how
it's time to have tamagotchi children
that mean they're talking about young
people who shouldn't have kids probably
because of climate change should have
robo ai children instead which is just
very very creepy
but i think it'll be fun it's a friday
night we're going to talk about a lot of
really important ideas and joining us to
discuss this is dr chloe carmichael hi
would you like to introduce yourself
sure so i'm dr chloe carmichael clinical
psychologist and author of nervous
energy harness the power of your anxiety
and dr chloe's ten commandments of
dating i was a yoga teacher before i was
a psychologist and i'm also a wife and a
mom
all right well we have a clinical
clinical psychologist to talk to us
about what it means to be a woman and
all those other things so thank you for
joining my pleasure we got seamus got
another expert here i'm a cartoonist um
so i run a youtube channel called
freedom tunes we just uploaded a video
like was any of that we just uploaded a
video like uh
two days ago that uh yesterday that i
think you guys will really enjoy and uh
we've got a website freedomtunes.com if
you want to become a member there five
bucks a month you'll get extra cartoons
every month an extra cartoon a week and
then behind the scenes stuff as well hey
guys ian crossland in the house what's
up uh i watched about 30 minutes of what
is a woman so far i'm really excited to
talk about what i've seen yeah not yet i
i launched into it about 6 30.
um and i want to talk to you a little
bit about your book well hopefully more
than a little bit about your book chloe
because i i wonder how to how to harness
that nervous energy myself sometimes
maybe we can get down on that later
sounds good yeah
and i am also here in the corner pushing
buttons trying to adjust all the volumes
properly for all my guests thank you
very much for joining us tonight chloe
i'm very excited to learn what a woman
is i did watch a documentary but they
were not big on answers so we'll
hopefully well matt walsh was yeah he
sure was well uh unsurprisingly ladies
and gentlemen today's show is actually
sponsored by the daily wire and what is
a woman yeah go to what is a woman.com
you know i i'm just going to say this
guys daily wire i i can't believe you
paid me to promote this because i was
already a fan of it and i was already
shouting it out so when they were told
like oh the daily wire would like it if
you shouted out what is a woman.com i
was like i'm already doing that but i'll
take the money yeah no it really is
really well produced it's really well
paced it's really really entertaining
and it's actually kind of scary in a lot
of ways matt walsh goes on a journey to
see if the question can be answered what
is a woman
talking with a bunch of experts and
unfortunately they can't seem to give i
don't want to spoil the movie but
you need to see how they respond to the
question anger animosity fear yo it's
absolutely ridiculous so check out what
is a woman.com sign up for the daily
wire we're big fans of the of the crew
over there i am extremely jealous of
this uh what is woman documentary
but again what is a woman.com also head
over to timcast.com become a member and
help support our work we have members
only segments monday through thursday at
11 p.m and uh
we talked about this yesterday when
tyler fisher who was on the show made
the joke i said i would ask someone what
is an assault weapon and he goes that's
the next documentary that the daily wire
shouldn't do anything no we're that's us
we're doing that and so i'm talking with
forrest cooper uh he's been a guest on
the show several times he hit me up and
he was like yeah no for real let's do it
i'm like yes
we are going to do a documentary on gun
control gun rights what is an assault
weapon is the is the working title i
suppose we're doing it it's happening
and i think it's really fascinating too
if you look back at the history of gun
control legislation and things like that
so with your support these are the kind
of projects that we're going to be
working on so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends let's
jump into that first story we got this
one from the daily caller
paul
young men of both political parties
think feminism does more harm than good
sounds it sounds like toxic masculinity
to me tim you're right except republican
women of all ages also really don't like
it interesting well but hold on what is
a republican woman
well i suppose
if we're talking about identities a
republican woman is a republican adult
human female
but a democrat woman could be something
totally different well because now that
i mean look look
obviously we have wonderful progress in
this era where a word can mean whatever
you want it to mean instead of what it
actually means and so maybe it's the
case unfortunately that there's a
negative side effect here where
men are just saying that they're women
disguising themselves as women and then
telling these pollsters feminism is bad
to make us think women oppose it what if
these are democrat what if these are
republican men who don't realize because
they identify as democrats that they're
not really democrats
i actually i'm not really men i actually
think that's an argument they would
entertain they're like well if a
democrat man says he hates feminism he's
actually a conservative there you go
yeah so he's just wrongly identifying my
biggest problem with it is that the
definition of feminism has changed over
the years there's actually four to five
waves of feminism my mother was raised
she raised me kind of as like a second
wave feminist where it was about
equality of opportunity for every person
didn't really matter what your gender
was and that was basically it it was
never like talking down to men it never
was about making men because i used to
ask you like as a question as a kid does
that mean men aren't bad does it mean
women are better and she said no no
there's about a quality of opportunity
for these people first wave feminism was
the we should get to vote right
we should have and second wave feminism
was that no more firm open palm slaps on
the behind from men in the workplace
kind of stuff like essentially like
equality in the workplace you know you
that that
i don't know 1950s era smoking you know
guy smoking like come here
that stuff's out the sexual revolution i
think being able to get credit cards and
bank accounts things like that in the
70s 60s that's fascinating though tell
me about that well it used to be that
women used to have a harder time with
that kind of thing you know being able
to get mortgages and bank accounts and
things so you know when
like the equal rights act and everything
was able to help us with that well so
but do you know why that was was it was
it like men and banks were like babe you
think i'm giving you a loan never gonna
happen yeah get out of here i i think i
think i was the 20s though by the way in
the 70s they were hippies right yeah i
think that it was you know just
previously not illegal to discriminate
against somebody because of their sex
and so you know maybe for whatever
reason banks just said you know well
maybe as a woman you're going to have a
baby and not pay your loan back or
whatever it was for whatever reason they
just didn't tend to extend credit to
women i think you know it probably was
the woman would go in to get a credit
card and they would say
and is your husband okay with this and
when they were like my husband doesn't
matter they'd say well he pays the bills
doesn't he so you know before women were
as prominent in the workplace or in
higher positions they probably just said
you you have lower credit just
inherently by not doing these jobs sure
it could be
well this is this is the kind of
feminism that most people are like yeah
that's cool you know like you shouldn't
discriminate on these like it should be
your job it should be your actual credit
not
you know you got boobs can't have a
credit card that seems like arbitrary
but these people act that's from 1963
signed by kennedy i haven't looked too
deeply into how it's uh read but equal
payback it's a labor law prohibits
gender-based wage discrimination i feel
like that was made redundant by the 1964
civil rights act could have been maybe a
precursor to that yeah
so now feminism you know probably the
reason young men don't like it is that
modern feminism is is what a catch-all
term for basically all sorts of weird
bigotry discrimination
rage even violence i think even from the
gecko though when there were arguments
to be made that women were being treated
unfairly in certain respects the
feminist movement was still mostly
pushing for this so to speak privileges
men had rather than the responsibilities
even at that time so for example
women couldn't vote they also couldn't
be drafted part of why many women didn't
want the right to vote at that time is
because they thought it was going to
come along with a duty to be drafted
which feminists at that time did not
argue for while they were arguing for
the vote
so you're saying women should be drafted
well no my point is that i think part of
the issue is even from the beginning
when we're discussing legitimate issues
feminists were more or less they were
saying men and women are equal and
should be treated equally in every
respect but then they would conveniently
ignore the responsibilities men had
which women didn't and not pursue
equality there
yeah with rights come responsibilities
um i looked it up also just to clarify
it was 1974 the equal credit opportunity
act to prohibit credit discrimination on
gender
wow well what's your what's your view
you're the the clinical psychologist
here i'm curious what your thoughts are
on modern feminism
yeah i mean that's a such a loaded issue
right um i mean i think tim that
probably i kind of go with you and in
the sense that i'm obviously for equal
rights for everybody
but i think a lot of women actually kind
of want the right to be more traditional
the right to be able to
be respected as a woman to be able to
recognize that homemaking and
housewifery and raising babies that
those things actually really matter and
you know girls getting kind of pushed
into this stuff
under the guise of girl power is
sometimes not quite so empowering also
as a boy mom myself meaning i'm a mom to
a son um i i think also some of this you
know girl power stuff has actually gone
a little bit too far to the point where
it's hurting boys which is actually also
hurting girls you know to the point
where girls don't want to date weak men
but that's unfortunately what some of
this like over-the-top girl power stuff
seems to be doing you say it hurts boys
like what's an example of that that
you've seen
well i mean so if if we
are
praising and helping girls to the point
where for example girls are outpacing
boys when it comes to college graduation
or graduate school girls are actually
also paid more than boys now on average
upon graduation from college so i mean
these are just a few examples but
obviously also boy's suicide rate is is
much higher um and other types of
problems and so when we're you know just
still for whatever reason still focusing
on you know more federal dollars to help
girls in school when in fact it's boys
who have a literacy crisis um so anyway
all of the focus on girls i think is
kind of um a little bit superfluous at
this point well this sounds like really
good news for young chads right if the
average man is making less money than
the women they're basically out of the
out of the dating pool and then the very
small proportion of chad young millennia
you know gen z men who are making all
the money get all the women you and you
see the problem well you see this all
the time whenever there's some twitter
thread that goes viral about someone
who's using tinder and she finds a guy
that she likes and she swipes on him and
then finds out he's been talking to 20
other girls it's like well that's
because you swiped on like 99 guys
swiped on that one guy and it was the
same thing for all the other girls so he
just had a bunch of options that's what
ends up happening when
the monogamous social standards break
down but also i agree with what you're
saying i think it's very interesting
because you'll have these nebulous
campaigns about how girls are called
bossy more often which isn't really
something we can test for have
statistics on and yet we ignore the fact
that boys are put on
that's an argument yeah but it's there
was a whole campaign ban bossy right and
we were told that we should all kind of
like hang our heads in shame because
when girls are assertive they're told
they're bossy and no one at the same
time will talk about the fact that
boys are more likely to be prescribed
adhd medicine in school they are
literally chemically altered because our
public educational system is failing
them and no one seems to consider it an
issue they also we're also chemically
altering young girls with birth control
yes
agree and well i think that's a problem
as well hormonal birth control causes
problems that no one's willing to
acknowledge i've never experienced a
work environment where people have
complained about a female who is bossy
like i've never i've heard the argument
but i've never been in an environment
where i'm like at lunch and someone's
like man that janet's so bossy i've just
never haven't i've heard people be like
my boss is a dick and i'd be like who's
your boss it's john i'm like oh mm-hmm
or like who's janet or it's jenna yeah i
don't like my boss how about that too
yeah i don't know it's just most people
don't like their bosses
you know i just it's a it's a weird
thing that's like i wonder if that is in
itself sexism these assumptions yeah
well the assumption of victimhood the
assumption here i'll tell you something
else man
i was talking to this guy who produces
documentaries and we were talking about
this issue and he was like he told me he
was like my experience was that whenever
we would have pitch meetings the women
in the meeting room would be giving us
stupid ideas and then everyone would be
getting really frustrated and annoyed
with these really dumb ideas and then
she would complain that no one takes her
opinion seriously because she's a woman
and we try to explain to her nose
because your ideas are dumb but she took
it to the female place instead of the
bad at her job place and you know it was
because she was brought into the room
because she was a woman because they
needed diversity it's true that can
happen and then also because women can
sometimes be more sensitive to criticism
right and and if you do criticize that
woman's ideas in the boardroom then you
know you can get this big reaction of
like you know well you know you're
you're undermining me because i'm a
woman or you're not taking me seriously
because i'm a woman and you know what
they're doing unfortunately then is
depriving themselves of the chance to
have real honest feedback and
collaboration and even to you know
engage and spar and develop and improve
because they're bringing it all you know
to being a woman and so then nobody does
comment nobody wants to say anything
unless it's going to be really you know
nicey nice and then they wonder why
nobody ultimately goes forward with
those ideas yep
i think when you have when you have uh
what's the quota filled roles
you're going to see a lot more of this
where people who are minorities or women
are going to feel like there's racism i
mean maybe that's maybe that's the goal
maybe maybe many of these activists want
to create this by putting people who are
unskilled in positions they're not
qualified for so that they feel
inadequate constantly and then the
person can come in and say oh that
feeling racism well we have to
understand this is a very very serious
problem because whenever we talk about
the idea of like marginalized
communities whether you're talking about
you know the alphabet people or you're
you're talking about people who are you
know minorities because of their ethnic
group in this country
the most serious problem i think is the
breakdown of the relationship between
men and women because that is the most
fundamentally important social
relationship that exists men are
supposed to open pickle jars
babies
well but no i mean we people will talk
about like sexism homophobia etc and i
think with sexism unfortunately whenever
there are issues that are addressed with
the relationship between the sexes it's
always in one direction the conversation
can only ever be
women are being treated unfairly and men
are bad and what's interesting about
that is there's actually kind of a
kernel of traditionalism and natural law
and that because people recognize that
it is the role of men to protect women
and to care for women and to provide for
them and so it's sort of bizarre because
we have this concoction where we're told
that men and women are exactly equal but
also men still have to fulfill this
traditional role of being the one who
cares for her and protects her and who's
tough and has a thick skin like remember
that amber heard taper she's like tell
him johnny tell him that you know that
you were abused you know and she's just
like you know see who believes you
exactly yeah yeah yeah
and then nobody talks about toxic
femininity of course you know but toxic
masculinity all the time is this big
thing so i think you're absolutely right
it's it's just it's so much more
normalized and comfortable for people
whether it's at school or work or
personal lives or whatever to just trash
talk men yeah well what is well can i i
just want to make a point about toxic
masculinity this is a term which they
always feign confusion over whenever
anyone points out that it's offensive it
is clearly an intentionally provocative
phrase if you wanted to get
authentically masculine men on board
with your project you would not label
their bad behavior as a form of
masculinity you would say something like
well actually these men are behaving in
an effeminate way when they treat women
poorly because they're not being men who
are protectors instead they label a
masculinity and go well why why would
you be against us calling it toxic
masculinity it's like because you're
attacking men in general and then
claiming you're only attacking a small
subsection so what is toxic feminine
femininity
well i mean so i don't mean to jump
ahead of ourselves but i mean i did
bring up amber heard right i mean i
you know so she's toxic when when we
when we think about toxic masculinity
they say that it's when you take things
that are traditionally masculine virtues
like maybe toughness or competitiveness
and you take them to a twisted extreme
right and so with women if you think
about it in in
spanish they have something called
marianismo and it's the opposite of
machismo so machismo is obviously we all
know what machismo is marianismo would
be almost like the kind of a counterpart
to that which is where you know there's
this extreme reliance on you know kind
of a victim
role right and with the amber herd thing
as well it was very interesting because
from a criminal psychology standpoint
attractive women will always fare better
in a courtroom than an unattractive
woman unless
it is shown that she used her
attractiveness to in some way carry off
the crime and then her attractiveness
will statistically turn against her
so about toxic femininity then that
would be the case of a woman who uses
her femininity her you know beguiling
feminine self in a way that um you know
twists and manipulates and deceives
people and i think part of why they will
never acknowledge that is because to do
so is to
understand and acknowledge that there
are certain benefits to being a woman i
think a lot of what we are seeing in
modern
in modern western culture the failures
are due to masculinity being gutted and
purged which is creating this imbalance
where
a massive outgrowth of femininity
becomes toxic and there's no strong men
to rebalance
so like you mentioned you all of a
sudden have the oppression olympics
everyone has to be a victim
toxic femininity is taking over
absolutely even to the point where they
have to make it up and you know what
it's not good for the women either i
mean i've sat with women in my office as
a clinical psychologist that have
expressed profound shame women you know
that are in their mid late 20s that say
you know back in college i cheated on my
boyfriend and i felt really bad about it
and i you know kind of said it was date
rape and you know i and and they they
they realized you know years later that
that they basically ruined somebody's
life um but at the time as soon as they
even kind of utter the words you know
well i he he he made me or whatever then
all of a sudden they activate this you
know big support network around them and
i've actually also spoken for an
organization called face families
advocating for campus equality and they
they try to assist young men who are
being what's called title ix at schools
now where it's it's a verb you know that
a woman can just say oh well you know he
raped me or you know he harassed me and
in many cases the man is actually
removed from school
immediately while the school does some
kind of a kangaroo court thing so toxic
femininity this is why the johnny depp
amber heard thing was such a big deal
for a lot of people i'm not gonna say
for everybody for a lot of people it was
just celebrity gossip but you had a guy
who was accused and he won
all of this me too stuff was just like
you had aziz ansari do you remember that
he had a bad date and no one was like it
was terrible so they try to go after him
it's it's insane that was insane because
i remember the woman said basically like
i went to his house i you know i think
she said she went down on him then she
gave him a [ __ ] you know what i mean
like and and and there was no talk of
him like forcing her to stay i mean
again like i think she like
of her own free will she mentioned how
he was like really nice and saying
things like you know we don't have to or
something like that yeah and i mean this
is why it actually hurts women i mean
and on the surface of it it looks like
oh look you know when women are wielding
this incredible power you know but but
the truth is is that it actually hurts
women it it infantilizes women it
suggests that we're not actually capable
of going out and having some drinks and
making our own choices and you know
being able to stand by them it's
actually hurting women right i would i
would argue part of what all of this
comes from is our society's insistence
upon oppressing the innate or
suppressing the innate understanding
that sex is a special thing so people
think they can just go out and do it
meaninglessly and then they regret it
but because the culture constantly
signals to them that there's nothing
wrong with doing it they wonder why do i
feel bad about this experience and i
think one conclusion they could draw
from it is there must have been some
coercive element here i must not have
chosen this because i've regretted this
and i've actually seen people say oh
yeah no if you regretted it then it was
coerced which is an insane thing to say
i will say the interesting thing about
it is in
modern culture we associate hookups with
regret that in tv shows and movies it's
like they wake up the next day like oh
man then you also have the walk of shame
of course after someone hooks up in
college and they're walking out of the
dorm or or the the fred or sorority
house it's like a shameful thing and i'm
like that's really weird for
us a society that's trying to tell
people it's it's it's shameless it's
prideful but then in every facet people
feel
something negative about the experience
it's so interesting to me that they
still feel shame i still firmly believe
that shame holds a very important role
in society and people just choose to
ignore it and one of the things i've
constantly said is that every sex scene
in every movie is completely unnecessary
because our culture does not believe
that sex means anything what's the point
of having sex you're just doing a thing
who cares are you deeply in love oh yeah
probably not i just watched the boys
sorry the uh i watched the first uh
episode i think it's the first episode
uh have you ever seen the boys no the
superhero show yeah
and in like the first 50 minutes there's
just like a ton of sex and then i was
like it didn't do anything for the story
at all you know i was like i get it
never does like we're sitting here and
they're like you know it does something
for the guy who made the story that's
why he put it in there exactly yeah i
guess like there's like a scene that
didn't even need to happen it happens
all the time
yeah i know it was just like what was
what was that namaste even even in films
that like even in films where you know
two people having sex was important to
the plot it's you never need to show it
it's very interesting that they choose
to so often
yeah yeah
well it's it's clear to me that they
just want it to be borderline
pornographic just to draw the eyes and
the cliques or whatever because
as far as i can tell in this culture sex
means nothing which is incredibly sad to
me but i i think there's a i think
there's a deeper question in you know
why why do humans have these hookups and
then regret it in the morning why is
that such a common thing that's they
still feel shame yeah like why
interesting if you hook up with like a
girl that's your friend that you're not
attracted to when you're both drunk and
then the next morning you're like oh god
what have i done i've changed the
dynamic of my relationship that's the
only shame i've ever felt walking out of
a girl's house but every other time it's
like hell yeah well so when when we
drink you know it almost kind of
for lack of a better word sort of
disables our executive love which is the
part of ourselves that you know thinks
about future consequences and things
like that nothing matters you know and
also of course when and when it's a
hookup situation you know one person is
usually kind of uh pouring on the charm
right so you know she's laughing at all
of his jokes he's telling her how good
she looks right and they're both making
a little bit of a concerted effort to to
get into each other's pants right so
it's almost like they're kind of on a
drug of euphoria in that moment and then
the next morning when you know reality
sets in
and lydia to your point about shame as
well just i want to back you up on that
there's a psychological healthy function
of shame which is to let us know when we
have broken our own boundaries and
broken our own standards there's
actually a healthy sense of um of when
we've come up short that's that serves
to guide us that we need to make a
change there was a viral story at a
college a poster was put up that said if
you are both drunk then like if you are
a man and you and the women are drunk
and you both hook up you raped her right
which is so insulting to women you know
what i mean because basically what that
is saying is that i need a chaperone if
i'm going to go out and have drinks you
know like that's where that goes it
means that i'm not able to just choose
anymore like how much to drink and when
i'm ready to go home with somebody i
mean i'm married now so i'm just
speaking
i'm pretty sure there was a story where
um yeah i i vaguely remember this i
think reason reported it a man and woman
both got drunk and hooked up at a
college and the man immediately went to
the school and reported her for raping
him and she got in trouble and they were
all freaking out and there's like that's
that's the way the game works he was
worried that she was gonna go and report
him so he reported her first and then he
wins because he reported her first
that's interesting but yeah i did want
to say i do think that the fact that a
woman can't have a few drinks and
maintain her bodily autonomy when i
started hearing about kids who are able
to change their gender at the drop of a
hat i was like this is so insulting that
i can't go out and have a beer and then
sleep not that i ever would i would
never i never had and now i'm married so
it's fine but it's like
that you would have no bodily autonomy
just by the mere act of drinking a few
drinks is ridiculous to me is treating
women like children let me pull up this
story because i simply googled it and i
found it from reason
male student accuses female student of
sexual assault says he wanted
she says he wanted revenge title ix
creates a prisoner's dilemma students
have to file sexual misconduct
complaints to avoid being the accused
this is actually really crazy the gist
of the story is that a male accuser uh
in an unusual move filed a title ix
complaint against her the female
students filed a lawsuit so this is an
inversion of what we typically see where
the male gets accused i think this guy
just knew what the game was good he's
like she's gonna falsely accuse me let's
go for it exactly it's kind of like what
sheamus was saying as well about how
this whole situation is eroding the male
female dynamic right where there's
almost like this you know race to see
who's who's gonna file on the other
person first you know defensively and
this is for people who just you know
made love look at this look at this it
says so there's uh was it jane rowe and
john doe because their names are blocked
out so the woman contends it was
ridiculous to find her guilty of
non-consexual sex because of of the
man's drunkness but not find him guilty
too because she was also drunk it
doesn't matter you made this game this
is what see this is this is why young
men are like feminism is bad because
this is what it results in it's like you
go into the bedroom you hook up and then
as soon as you're done you're both
looking at each other looking at the
door and then you're both running full
speed trying to accuse each other of
being the aggressor that's completely
insane yes i don't it's nuts i i don't
maybe i'm taking a different view of
hookup culture i i kind of went through
it in the 90s no well more than 2000
early 2000s late 90s but i never really
found it abhorrent or i had a problem
with it like i would hook up with a girl
uh we would both have a great time and
then that would be that and then i would
never really if we would or wouldn't
talk again after that it was just really
fun you know sex is fun it's like why do
you people snowboard
it's fun it's exercise yeah but
snowboarding doesn't carry the risk with
it of like creating another human life
and i shouldn't even call a risk right
creating a human life is a beautiful
thing but what if he was bringing his
wife you got to the bottom of the
mountain you said a baby
then you know what we would have we
would have some very strong social
stigmas around who you went snowboarding
with probably and how often you
snowboarded and whether you having
whether you were snowboarding outside of
marriage i think that's true dad where
do babies come from well son when a men
and women love each other they go
snowboarding by the time they reach the
bottom of the mountain what about the
people who ski that's unnatural
[Laughter]
you are right it's not a sport sex is
not a sport and it shouldn't be treated
like that i mean i feel like the path
we're on it will be yeah like you're
gonna have weird it's a race to the
court yeah yeah well right now it's it's
a sprint it's like you're in college and
you hook up you both are like
well uh uh that was great i'm i'm gonna
go to bed and then you like the guy
starts like speed walking towards the
the title nine office or whatever and
then he gets halfway he like he's like
halfway there and then all of a sudden
down the end of the hallway he sees the
woman and they just both bolt for the
door like uh running towards it that's
that's where this is going you gotta oh
sorry no no you go delineate between sex
has the the pregnancy aspect which is
what but also the orgasm which is like
i mean that's
you get better at it the more you do it
from my experience and the more you
study it so like if someone's like never
will have sex only until they're about
ready to have a baby then they're
missing out on the opportunity to
you know give their partner an orgasm or
50 organizations
i would disagree did you know
uh i think i think you all might know
this that women
who uh
abstain from sex until marriage report
greater satisfaction isn't that that's
yeah i'm pretty sure yes and they're
also the least likely to divorce yeah
right it is true it is true and also i
just wanted to say i know that you said
you had a certain experience in college
with sex that was different from this
you know kind of race to the courtroom
thing
and i wanted to just mention that it was
in 2014 that the obama administration
announced this new effort to combat
sexual assault on campuses and i think
that's really when this whole thing of
like title ix somebody and like you know
young men if they're accused that they
have to be removed immediately like
while this kangaroo court situation
happens so if you were able to graduate
from college before 2014 it might have
been a different world though oh yeah it
was in 2001 that's when i graduated oh
yeah well you know i've sort of said
this before you know i'm i'm a
traditionalist i wear that on my sleeve
but what the left often does is in the
long run after they've broken down the
social boundaries they try to imitate
traditionalism but in a much more
convoluted way and so what we see is as
it would be the case in the past people
uh do get in trouble for having sexually
immoral encounters but because we don't
know how to label a consensual sexual
encounter as immoral people jumped to it
was assault now obviously yes there are
people who are genuinely assaulted and
there should be resources for them but
it just happens to be the case that they
have this entire infrastructure set up
with these kangaroo courts which as
we've described will punish people for a
crime that they did not commit it will
charge them not as someone who's
fornicated but as someone who has raped
it's interesting because also from a
psychology perspective we think about
internal locus of control versus
external locus of control so internal is
where i believe that i'm the one in the
driver's seat in my life i'm the one
choosing if i have those drinks and
sleep with that guy or whatever else and
the external locus of control is you
know oh well it was the situation it was
the patriarchy i was you know whatever
in as if the world is happening to us
like the weather and psychology studies
have shown that people with an internal
locus of control tend to you know be
less vulnerable to things like anxiety
and depression it's a it's a factor of
resilience to feel that you have
self-efficacy and that you are in charge
of your own decisions so i do think that
this whole thing um has not been good
you know for women or for men when we
start seeing that it's not just
you me and the lamp post you know
deciding what we're doing here but that
we think we start blaming all these
social factors instead of just looking
at our own behavior i mean that's that's
the culture war in a nutshell yeah
people being like it's not my fault i
did it it's patriarchy is that like a
result of psychoactives being introduced
to young people that they now have less
of an internal locus of control they're
they're seeing it happier i i think that
there's been this big movement you know
to to to to d shame women right for if
they want to have sex and you know
whatever they want to do you know girl
power again all of that kind of stuff
and so therefore if a woman does have
regrettable sex
maybe within that framework it wouldn't
really be permissible for her to say you
know i feel shame i don't feel like
that's good for me i don't think i want
to do that again because then she'd have
to look at herself and say that she
wants to do something differently which
would go against the grain of this other
narrative of saying women are just like
men you can go have sex all the time
with a bunch of people and you'll be
fine um and so then because she she
can't blame her you know her own choices
then the only alternative is to start
blaming other people
and there are no strong men
to stand up and say enough i mean there
are but they're all right-wing now i
mean even if they're not right-wing
they're right-wing that's what's
happening that's what they're joe rogan
is a right-wing comedian i suppose
because if cause if you have any kind of
masculinity i mean this is probably why
they call joe rogan right wing he's a
meat head
he is a ripped mma dude who goes bow
hunting for elk
he's got left-wing politics but that
doesn't matter he's masculinity yeah you
need a dude that'll stand up and say
enough but also that will cry
in feeling what she is feeling like
jordan peterson so i think he's kind of
the embodiment of the strong man right
now peterson seems to be although he's
not a meat head and i don't know what he
mentions
when we when we had uh we had tyler
fisher on the other night and he said
that he he was raised by two dads he
said that he was very much you know woke
and everything until he started
listening to jordan peterson and jordan
peterson helped him get to get his life
in order and i'm like that's exactly why
they fear jordan peterson so much
teaching teaching young men personal
responsibility teaching young men to be
masculine that is very dangerous for
people who don't want that balance
brought back to the force absolutely and
so i've said this before on the show i
honestly mostly blame men for feminism i
think the reason women are acting like
men is because men are acting like
children and people will usurp the roles
that are not being fulfilled by the
people who are responsible for them in
some sense and so i think we're in a
position where society has basically as
you've mentioned put a lot of emphasis
on areas where we think women might be
falling behind relative to men whenever
men are falling behind that's never
really considered a problem
and so now we have a system where women
are actually able to
um contribute to the economy in the
workforce in a way that a lot of men
can't compete with within the romantic
marketplace and so
a you have that but then b it's far
outside of an economic issue it's also
an issue of virtue like men are not
taught to see women as people who they
should love and protect and care for
think about what porn has done to men's
brains it has convinced them that women
are objects for their own sexual
pleasure and not human beings who they
should love and in commune with and
genuinely care for and protect well to
tie together what you were saying about
women being told they shouldn't feel
ashamed for sleeping with a bunch of men
it makes me
angry to a certain degree that women are
told that they need to behave like men
you need to work you need to fight you
need to do all of this stuff you need to
take action against people who take
advantage of you you don't actually need
to do that and the fact of the matter is
that men and women view sex very
differently i understand that i'm okay
with that i'm not fighting against that
because it's a biological imperative
women connect much more deeply than men
with sex on a very emotional level
because women tend to be more emotional
and that's okay that's fine that's
wonderful it's beautiful men are not the
same even at a neurochemical level like
women release a bunch of oxytocin it's
really it's really crazy because did you
know that the better the sex is the more
orgasms the woman has the more oxytocin
she releases right so the more bonded
she gets to the guy the
better the sex is for her exactly which
is awful right because like if you go
out and you're going to have that one
night stand well
it better be good right you're not doing
it for relationship fulfillment right
it's just a you know sex and then you
end up getting like really bonded to the
person well that that explains why uh
women who are abstained from sex until
marriage tend to report greater
satisfaction of course so i read that
i'm not gonna i'm not saying i know for
a fact i don't have the evidence pulled
up but i'm you know that that is the
case
and for men the more like orgasms and
the more forceful orgasms that they have
right
fine great and the more testosterone
they get their testosterone rises and
rises which makes them you know just
more and more independent and all these
other things right
it's really hard for women
i want to ask you this um
dr chloe
so i was thinking about dating apps and
we've talked about this on the show
before
i was talking to this young guy
this is a few years ago he was like 26
and he was a virgin and hadn't had a
girlfriend
and he was saying that it was basically
impossible and through the conversation
it was interesting basically what he was
saying was that you know all everyone
dates through tinder and other apps and
stuff so he's on there but he can never
get any responses and i was like
interesting i started reading some uh
data from dating websites
and it looks like what may be happening
in colleges
you have
20 year old men and women let's just use
an average age
they're all on tinder the 20 year old
man has no status has no wealth he's in
college so when he reaches out to a peer
a 20 year old woman and he says want to
hang out she goes sure what did you have
in mind we can go to the the courtyard
and we can like talk and she's like
that's cool then she swipes right on a
30 year old guy who makes 70 80 000 a
year he's got a got a nice car he's got
his own apartment and he says you want
to hang out what do you want to do and
he says we can drive to the lake go see
a movie then come back to my place i've
got drinks and she goes done yeah even
more he doesn't just say you want to
hang out he says would you like to go
have dinner right you know like from the
start he's whining and dining a little
more
so
it feels to me that
dating apps have expanded the dating
pool so massively that young men no
longer have a peer group in which they
can find a mate
and higher status men now get access to
basically every
every available woman so what we started
seeing is this was reported by the
washington post
that i think a third of men under 29
were virgins
and
you know unmarried as well not dating
that that was i think four years ago so
it's probably gone up since then
something is happening i'm wondering if
you uh you know what your thought is on
dating apps and if you would agree yeah
yeah i totally agree with what you said
about the numbers game and you know the
fact that now that 20 year old woman as
as well she's going to be this like hot
item you know if she's open to going out
with 30 year old guys right so she it
really shifts the the dating dynamics
and then also you know i've read
something similar about the virginity
rate like amongst you know very young
people and i think it may also have to
do with the proliferation of porn you
know as sheamus was saying i mean to
really get out there and like you know
find somebody it's even for a one-night
stand you know it's it's not easy right
you have to take certain social risks
you have to put yourself out there you
have to deal with rejection you know
there's so many hurdles that you have to
clear and if young men are able to get
their appetites you know pretty much
fully satisfied from the comfort of
their own home for less money and less
effort i can see where they would have
less motivation as well and then as you
said if the dating app dynamics are
making it even harder for them
yeah and i think that's that's
absolutely correct and it's not just
that their need is satisfied in some
sense it by virtue of what it is you
only have to think about yourself in
your own pleasure and not another human
being who you're involved with and on
top of that it's very sad when you see
how the dynamic is played out because
men will point out the fact that women
have all these options on these
dating apps the reality is most women
want to find one man to be monogamous
with and they're not able to do that
because guess what the guy they're
interested in because he's at the top of
the dominance hierarchy so to speak he's
got a bunch of other women who are into
him and he's messing around with all of
them and he's not going to commit to any
one of them so it's this this this
horrific like sexual hellscape where no
one gets what's going to make them happy
or or it's a revert to a primitive state
where the alpha
just gets all the women yeah we need
everything
i'm pretty sure what chimps do is like
the chimps all beat the crap out of each
other and the chimp who wins bangs all
the girls all the women you know it's
also interesting too with prides of
lions when um like uh the the males from
a warring pride come and like defeat the
males of another pride the females of
the defeated pride will immediately go
sleep with the victorious males
not loyal man wow you know but i mean
also sheamus to your point about about
them getting their needs satisfied you
you kind of touched on something there
that i think is important too which is
that young men who are sexually
inexperienced you know virgins they
might think that they're getting their
needs satisfied in the sense that like
that they're seeing porn and they're
having an orgasm check
but like they don't know the pleasure of
like being with a woman and
you know laughing together and and the
the touch and the intimacy and the fun
of it because they haven't experienced
it so they might think that they're
getting satisfied but they don't realize
that they're not really getting it all
yeah
i think a lot of them know and are very
bitter about that i think a lot of them
know that they're not really getting a
full authentic experience and that they
are sort of being cynically exploited by
the people who produce this kind of
hideous stuff and that it's inhibiting
their ability to have real relationships
when you have an orgasm with alone in
your room you're losing a lot of fluid
like there it goes but when you're with
a woman you're introducing the fluid to
them they're introducing the fluid to
you and so you're getting something
you're not just not just a net loss when
you're with someone it's a trade and
that's a very different feeling like um
emotional or like chemical chemical
experience uh correct me if i'm wrong
but i think a better way i think i i
think this may be more accurate there is
like a a the exchanges in what you smell
that triggers certain you know blood
flow and release of chemicals in the
brain
right yeah yeah there's definitely
things that you smell but i mean it's
also even the the sense of being held
and squeezed and you know just felt and
loved and and kissed and and known i
mean there's just there's a there's an
interpersonal component to sex
but isn't that insane that you should
even have to say that
confidence when men and women smell each
other their blood flow increases their
like blood vessels dilate chemicals get
released
i think it depends on how he smells to
be fair for the woman i think if he
smiles no no no all right i was making a
joke no no so the point i'm making is
that if the woman is attracted attracted
to the man or if the man smell like i'm
not saying the smell makes the
attraction or the attraction makes a
smell but there is a correlation between
a man smelling good and woman being
attracted to him pheromones that's the
released there's that famous documentary
series they did the science of sex
where they had a bunch of dudes run on
treadmills took their shirts off and put
them in jars then had women come in and
smell each shirt and write whether it
smelled good or bad and it turns out the
women who said the shirts smelled that
some the women
said some shirts smelled bad they would
be related to that man
yeah that's crazy they said oh this one
smells good they were not related if it
smelled bad they they're like that was
your brother and she's like oh wow
i noticed also you didn't even need to
see him to know it's not a mate for not
a potential mate it would be bad right
it's funny because i've known girls who
like really complain about the way that
their brothers smell yeah right exactly
and then i was reading that they tell
women if they're going to get married to
get off birth control yes because it
negatively impacts their like recep like
sensory reception to the man
and then when they stop taking the birth
control they say stop taking it wait a
few weeks and if your man smells bad you
can't get married i've noticed also
about sexual intercourse is that it
builds confidence and i like the word
confidence because it has the word
confide like you're actually um
confidant
and you're you're basically interacting
with another person in this like really
primal primally evocative you know
proactive manner and you're able to make
eye contact for instance and it's like
the level of confidence that you get out
of that is not even remotely uh
there in porn it's nothing like that
nothing it's a completely other it's
basically having a friend like a really
good friend oh my gosh i could see where
porn would almost be like the opposite
right because like you know you're
you're sitting there and you're like
either like paying some website or you
know you're like
basically doing something where you're
validating to yourself almost the idea
that that that you can't get somebody or
whatever you know so it's almost like
invalidating but it's also it's also it
warps people's minds
the the the the weird
the weird stuff on the internet is so
far outside of the realm of reality it
used to be like a dude would be like i'd
like to be in bed with that woman now
it's a guy being like i would love to
swing from a ceiling fan while bungee
jumping you know like just all the weird
crazy and it really fosters that right
because if you are in the context where
you are married to a woman who you're
having sex with you love this person you
don't want to do anything to her that
would be considered degrading so if
there is some intrusive thought or weird
fantasy you're not going to indulge it
with pornography first of all there's no
one there to check you so there's no one
there to be like that's a weird thing to
want you can literally search whatever
you want and then people just people are
obsessed with novelty and so they search
for more and more deranged things and
when you look at the fact that erectile
dysfunction rates have increased as much
as they have it's almost certainly
attributable to the wide accessibility
of pornographic materials especially to
boys who are still teenagers i think i
think i think jordan peterson talked
about that right like young maybe i'm
wrong but i was reading something where
young men are watching this ridiculous
you know fake reality stuff and then
when it comes to the real world thing
they're like i don't know what this is
exactly
but i do want to i don't want to say
look man i think if people want to be
kinky and do stuff in the bedroom and be
whatever they want to be or whatever i
got notion with that
my issue is when people start separating
themselves from reality with weird stuff
that's just like like i said like
swinging from a ceiling fan while
jumping out of a plane and then throwing
the ceiling just like weird that's not
going to happen i mean i guess if you
want to if you're rich enough to make
that happen and you want to bang someone
while jumping out of a plane there's a
big difference between two people having
sex where they're not looking at each
other they don't even know each other's
they don't care it's just two bodies
smashing together the girl's in pain
because it's like so hard but and then
the situation where it's two people that
are connecting to each other and they
feel each other's bodies they're not
moving to hurt they're not ignoring the
other person while they're just pounding
and it's like but the internet doesn't
know how to to differentiate between
that and so the kids see both and they
don't know what's supposed to be good or
bad and then used to get the warping
effect kids shouldn't see it at all
there's another argument the average age
now is 11 that kids are born to tim's
point also about the just what we call
in a need for an increasing stimulation
right so the first time maybe that you
sit down and look at porn online you're
even just getting some adrenaline from
that because you know you're doing
something taboo and so your body because
of the extra adrenaline will actually
sometimes have a more intense sexual
experience like there have been some
studies even that showed that people who
just walked across a scary bridge that
was really old and rickety that they
would rate people as more attractive
than people who had just walked across a
very safe bridge so when people you know
use porn to a certain degree it's almost
like a drug but then once you've seen
the same stuff a million times it
becomes sort of ho-hum and so then
people just need to keep doing as tim
was saying stuff that's you know even
more and more bizarre to kind of keep up
that sort of a hit and then there's the
other factor which is that these sites
make money by getting you to spend more
time on it and so they'll be popping up
stuff that you might never have even
thought of but there you are with your
your body physiology all turned on to
the point where you could look at a
baked potato and think it was sexy right
and then and then you end up with a guy
in the hospital with a broken light bulb
in his ass yeah
were you thinking dude who's on the
internet
i mean your studies of psychology what
is like a good tactic for people to
maintain that adrenaline rush with their
partner well so i actually have an
article about that um it's called don't
have chemistry with nice guys here's how
to change that
um if anybody wants to um email me
through my website i'll send you a copy
of the blog if you can't find it um but
so what what i suggest people do like
this is it's kind of old-fashioned but
like that's why people go to horror
movies on dates because like it kind of
like gets things going a little bit you
know or do even going to like new places
new restaurants that kind of thing um
escape rooms anything that just gets
your blood going and gets that kind of
excitement going um will kind of
transfer onto the sex yeah actually i
actually read that um when women are
scared they generate a stronger bond
with the person they're on a date with
yeah correct they need to and so there
was a i think it was a study about they
you know monitored people on dates and
and they had them walk across a rickety
bridge
and the women reported like higher
bonding or satisfaction with their date
when they were walking across a rickety
it's really weird well i mean trauma
bonding right is not not a real
phenomenon i'm curious about this well
it's even just the increase in
adrenaline right so so when you have
more adrenaline going you know your your
heart is beating faster you're getting a
little sweaty um it's it's almost like
the same as being turned on you know and
so you're you're just experiencing all
of your physical sensations more
intensely and also you're you're
blocking out thoughts of anything else
because your mind goes into this tunnel
vision yeah fight or flight yeah but i
think i think even beyond the studies
we've done on this stuff there's there's
like the joke in in tv shows and movies
where the guy stages a mugging to
impress the date
it's like that that we just knew that we
knew that you go on a date with a woman
and then if if the guy defends or he
looks tough it's attractive and then we
do science we're like oh yeah that
actually happens or the girl stages a
damsel in distress moment and you know
the man comes to her rescue are there
dietary things that can improve
adrenaline i i don't know about that i
don't know so the interesting thing is
the the relationship dynamics are
changing so dramatically now that
femininity is sort of being washed away
we have this story that we've talked
about quite a bit actually i mean we've
done multiple segments on it i want to
bring it up so that we can talk about
with you dr chloe the new york post
writes women are struggling to find men
who make as much money as they do
and so they talk about these women uh
who are like you know a 30 year old
who's 38 year old making 50 000 a year
or something and she can't find a man
and you know when i first talked about
this boy did every feminist lose their
mind they were like tim paul how dare
you and i said here's my assessment
if you're a 38 year old man
and you're making 50 000 a year
why would you want to date a 38 year old
woman who's making 50 000 a year when
you can date a 28 year old woman who's
making less and you can provide and
actually feel uh appreciated
like
it's it's this older guy
he's gonna date a younger woman because
he has the money to do so it feels good
for him because she appreciates what
he's able to give to her and he feels
like he's able to give something but
dating a woman of the same age he's not
offering anything it doesn't feel good
and why would she want to date someone
who's not a provider so ultimately what
ends up happening is
guys like dating younger women so older
women who are career women are going to
have a harder time
yes they do they do i mean i can just
from my own practice you know it's it's
a difficult thing you know and and women
i'm not saying this to be against women
i'm actually really seeing it in
sympathy with women that women who who
do get older will say that it becomes
harder and harder for them to date yeah
because for a variety of reasons whether
it's
the fact that more of their age peers
are married or that maybe their age
peers are hoping to have kids and so
they're trying to date a younger woman
so that they have time to do that you
know i think that's why a lot of women
are freezing their eggs i think women
would um
they need to pay attention to the
leonardo dicaprio principle
but i mean it i know i know what you're
talking about would you want to explain
what leonardo dicaprio does leonardo
dicaprio regardless of his age dates
women who are in their early twenties
and only up to a certain age and then
like every woman's like 25 and then he
breaks up with her then 25. so here's my
point
i don't i saw a headline it was like
this is on twitter it's pretty funny
it's like leonardo dicaprio's exes where
are they now and the top reply was
probably in their late 20s
that's great so here's why i say this
25 year old man
he's going to date a 22 year old woman
35 year old man he's going to date a 22
year old woman 45 year old man he's
going to date a 22 year old woman you
see these these old men you know and
they're like 70 and they're wealthy and
they're dating 20 year old women
so as women get older
no matter what they could provide it's
let's say you're 40 and you don't make
that much money and you're hoping to
find something maybe maybe you'll find
someone older because they want younger
the the rich guy can still get the 20
year old woman and i'm not saying it
should be that way but the reality is if
a man at no matter what age i mean we've
seen 80 year old men with 20 something
year old women like you're robbing the
cradle and it's like i don't care i'm
old and i'm going to die and she's like
and then he doesn't i get his money
there they they like it
so the problem there is there's a
certain point for women where
no matter how old the guy is if he has
resources he will go for the 20 30 year
old woman
right and you know it kind of takes me
back to the article that you mentioned
when we started the poll showing that
you know younger uh men thought feminism
had done more harm than good but that
that was less true of a belief for for
young women to have and i couldn't help
but think about the fact that yeah
that's that's young women that that
they're currently saying oh yeah the
world is just telling me that i can have
it all i can do this i can do that and
everything else why wouldn't they like
that message right but when we start
talking about the older women who are
then saying yeah okay so i spent my 20s
climbing the career ladder and not
having kids and how is this feminism
really necessarily helped me so much i
would be curious about women you know
that are in their 30s for that poll the
interesting thing about all of these
polls
that take a look at feminism and dating
and stuff is that they don't understand
the difference in generations so when
they say did you know that women on
average make 17 or you know 23 percent
less than men it's like are you talking
about all age groups are you factoring
in only gen x and below because if you
do that then all of a sudden you realize
women make more than men
the problem is it's very simple in the
60s and 70s women didn't work the same
jobs as men they didn't make as much
money now they're they're they're
growing up
there is a disparity in the boomer
generation there was a disparity in the
silent generation the disparity is
mostly going away but the narrative
persists i mean the narrative of the pay
gap is wrong for a million one reasons
but what's happened now it's inverted
young women are more likely to graduate
college more likely to go to college
more more likely to get higher paying
jobs than their male counterparts but
because we lump in boomers with
millennials in the same stats it
presents this narrative of female
victimhood when boomers are long gone it
is going to be inverted and women will
make more than men well also it's
interesting that it's considered
victimhood right because what is
necessarily wrong with women choosing
not to work as much or choosing to work
fewer hours or just choosing not to work
at all because they want to have a
family why is that seen as like some
horrible form of oppression when they're
making that choice for themselves you
know feminists will often make the
argument that they just want women to be
able to make their own choices they're
not here to try to force a specific
social order under the greater ho under
the greater whole of society but
all of the decisions women make that
they complain about happen to be the
more traditional ones so it's clear that
they're not interested in letting women
make their own choices they have a
specific set of of standards they think
women should be living by for them
who's they that said that feminist i
mean that's feminism every single time
they complain about a disparity between
men and women it's a disparity uh which
is an indicator that women are behaving
more traditionally or taking on a more
traditionally feminine gender role you
know and i think it is i think it is
social pressures
beget social pressures
i think that there was a genuine issue
with with equal opportunity women
complained about it so then people said
let's do a big pr campaign and tell
women they can be equal this created
social pressure among women to be
those fighting for equality because that
was the social cause the social cause is
speeding up it's going faster and faster
this is why i think young men don't like
modern feminism because women are
chasing
i shouldn't say women necessarily
but the the feminine is chasing after
social acceptance in a rapid degree
regardless of what that outcome is it's
also
financial gives you uh like an air of
independence because if the men and
women were dating and the girl the guy
has all the money he's got a job she
doesn't and
she's like i want to eat uh rabbit
tonight and the guy's like well i'm
paying for it so we're eating pizza but
i think the problem is not that she
doesn't have money the problem is she's
dating an [ __ ] if that's the case
maybe but after then
they're like okay let's get married and
it can be our money and the guy's like
you know what i'm the one making our
money so we're eating pizza so that's a
horrible husband to go back to the point
i was trying to make maybe she should
get a job the point i'm trying to make
is that women feel pressured to do
things they're seeing on social media or
in the news because they think that's
what they have to do to be accepted to
be acceptable so they're adopting
certain behaviors they're uh putting on
certain messages they're holding up
certain signs
because they all just chase after each
other's message well there's no one to
tell them like hey that's too much women
and girls are more vulnerable to what's
called social contagion right so that's
why like for example like in the 80s
like it seemed like every woman like had
an eating disorder you know or like
there's just certain things that can
suddenly crop up right and i think that
sometimes that can happen for for women
and girls as well when we get bombarded
with this messaging you know that we're
supposed to you know do certain things
in in career and that we can't even talk
about you know wanting something
different like from the psychology side
also
psychology studies have shown that
people on the left are
more collectivist and people on the
right politically tend to be more
individualist right and so one of the
both both sides have their extremes
which can be you know not so good but
when it comes to collectivism
one of the things that can happen is
that you can get attached to the
narrative of the group right and there's
you know group think to the point where
you don't even feel comfortable stepping
out of the narrative that's why it does
feel so insanely controversial for young
women to say you know i i'm not sure
that i i want to be a partner at a law
firm you know
yeah that's a very good point you know
you made this point earlier where you
said you'd be curious to know how women
would respond to being asked the
question of whether feminism was a net
positive once they're in their 30s or
older i think another thing we have to
consider is whether we should just be
asking women about the specific results
of feminism and asking them whether
they're happy with that because if you
just use the term oftentimes i think
what people are going to do is look at
what they think that movement intends
and not necessarily what its results are
so if you ask women questions like are
you happy with the fact that it's more
difficult for you to find a man who
makes as much money as you are you happy
with the fact that it's harder for you
to start a family i mean almost all of
them would say no
i thought chloe what you said about the
left being more collectivist the right
being more individualist or independent
i guess individualist the extreme of the
right individualism would be like what i
was saying earlier the guy and the girl
are in a relationship the guy makes more
money and he's like so he i'm gonna
decide what we do because i'm the one
bringing the money and the money is
what's gonna get the thing and that's
like the the ex so that's the the
extreme of the individualism that's
that's i disagree
well i don't necessarily disagree i just
want to say that what likely would occur
is the woman saying i'm breaking up with
you i'm leaving right women have a
choice and if the man is is too in one
direction then it just breaks apart so
maybe i should say i should say i agree
with you that degree of individualism
would probably break down yeah yeah
that's the extreme going too far
what i wanted to say though is that i
think the extreme of individualism would
be the man beating the woman jeez god i
mean that's the extreme well he clearly
doesn't at that point cares so little
for her well-being he causes her harm
right
so
i'm thinking about like prenuptials do
you as i guess through your psychology
do you think prenuptials are i feel like
prenuptials should be written into
marriage without even like the option
personally but what do you think about
those i don't have a prenup personally
so you know i mean i i think it's gonna
be different for each person um but no i
mean i i just personally
view marriages as a as the kind of
commitment that you make without um
having without needing or wanting to
have like kind of a if we break up plan
because the plan is no matter what
happens we're not breaking up however um
i i am i'm an individualist and i
totally get that every marriage is
different and if other people say that
they just feel better with a prenup i
don't i don't have any problem with that
i i gotta say if you think you need a
prenup you should not get married yeah
don't don't but that's why i think they
should be written in without you having
to think about it no no no i disagree i
disagree why would getting married to
someone mean that all of your wealth
from the last 40 years of my life would
would now be gone if she decided to
leave me that's insane because marriage
is till death do us part
if you're trying to date someone you
don't need a prenup and if you're
pledging your life to another person you
shouldn't need one and if you do
maybe you should reconsider please you
know the issue is no fault divorce
though right like so i i can understand
kind of like what you both are saying
like and i guess well like i don't have
a prenup i i wouldn't want to be you
know enter into marriage that way but i
can also understand where you know for
for a man or a woman that had built up a
lot of wealth and we're now getting into
this you know legal contract that's um
you know supposed to represent a
spiritual commitment but then we're
making it a legal contract and part of
that legal contract isn't structured
around a lifelong agreement like it used
to be because we got rid of no because
now we have no fault divorce so i can i
could understand no fault divorce i
agree yeah well and i think also and
sorry just no no the courts are heavily
biased in favor of women yeah to an
insane degree especially with children
and men well you know it's funny because
we live in this culture where no fault
divorce is the law of the land
and people will say things like well
look how often marriage ends in divorce
how could you ever be in favor of social
structures which disincentivize that or
would you know dissuade people from
getting divorced but i think what people
often miss is if young folks know
they're in an environment where divorce
is not an option i firmly believe
they're going to be more careful about
who they choose to marry and i think
also people are going to be more careful
about their decision-making in general
when it comes to sexuality a lot of
people will start sleeping with someone
and as you've mentioned that releases
oxytocin and other hormones that bond
you and there are a lot of couples that
end up together because they're sexually
engaging with one another and they're
bonding but they're not actually really
good for each other and then at some
point in the marriage when the novelty
of that person wears off they get
divorced so i think it's not just that
we have no fault divorce in people who
would otherwise be staying married or
getting divorced i think they're
actually making poor choices about who
they end up marrying because of the
current status quo a starter marriage
it's like a phrase it's horrifying
that's horrible
what's that like training wheels i don't
know it's just it's something i've heard
young women talk about it's like a
starter marriage or it's even worse but
i've heard young women say like you know
first marriage is for money second
marriage is for love wow wow
yeah i know i know and this is this is
this is
this is ruining relationships
it's uh we were talking about this the
other day
that uh
we're citing jordan peterson so often in
this quest he was saying something that
after 35 you better have a family
because that's when things are to break
down that's what the convert were you
you're interested or no no no i don't i
don't think so yeah when what things
start to break down when you start to
you're gonna be lonely you're gonna have
no friends like if you don't start a
family around 35 you're gonna be
yeah this is colloquially called the
wall and i'm sure you've heard of it if
you've been a denizen of the internet
for any length of time all women
supposedly hit a wall when they're about
35 and if you don't have a family you
are gonna be lonely and you're gonna
have a problem you're not gonna be able
to find a good date it doesn't matter
how much money you make because that's
not what men look for in a spouse i do
think that there are exceptions to that
i i agree with you for the most part and
you know for me as a psychologist again
i've sat with women you know going
through some really rough times you know
in those situations but
there are also women that just they
never want to get married they never
want to have kids they have almost like
and i mean this in a in a loving fond
way they have a a peter pan type of
existence you know they they just want
to have their dog they want to go to
brunch they they make a lot of money and
and they're they're quite happy they
they don't want to give of themselves in
the way that it takes to be to be a wife
to be a mom so i i don't want to you
know deny that there are women for whom
that actually works out do you think
that's a chemical imbalance or is that
just natural i don't i don't think it's
a chemical imbalance you know i i i
don't know what it is but um i just
wanted to to just make make room for the
fact that while i do think it's true
what tim said for the most part and
that's definitely the majority of what i
see as a psychologist but there are
women that just made their own thing
maybe we would just be better off if i
don't know you know women had to wear
red dresses and bonnets
it's funny because you know you so
you've sort of mentioned that being the
exception to the rule and lydia brought
up this idea of the wall part of what's
so unfortunate and really sultifying the
discourse on basically everything is
that people confuse making like a
prescriptive claim and a descriptive
claim so
by lydia mentioning that there does seem
to be this point at which it's going to
be significantly more difficult for a
woman to find a partner that she's
saying that that's good and so because
of that people are just reluctant to say
that to young women they're reluctant to
share the truth with them about what
could possibly await them if they don't
get married before a certain point of
time and i think that's really
horrendous i think that's a really
horrible thing to do to young women you
should tell them the realistic
possibilities for their life instead of
trying to claim everyone can do
everything and then having them end up
miserable because they had completely
unrealistic expectations because of you
my prediction is millennial women will
not admit it this single millennial
women they're chasing their careers
many of them are probably doing it due
to social pressures many of them are
doing it because they really want to do
it and for that i nothing but respect of
the women who are not being honest with
themselves and are more concerned about
social pressures than what they truly
would want maybe a family
i don't think they'll admit it they'll
be 40 and they'll say no life's great
i've never been happier young women will
see it they'll be 45. i love my life i'm
single and i'm living up in the big city
they're going to be 55 and they're going
to say you know well it has its charm
they're going to be 60 and they're going
to go to the young people and say i've
made a terrible mistake don't make the
same mistake i did yeah but by that
point there's going to be a generation
or two that believed the lies yeah do
you guys think that there's such thing
as a soul mate
no
i've wondered this because i think that
being in the wrong relationship is worse
than being single personally from my
personal experience
and so i was looking for the soul mate i
spent decades alone lonely you know and
uh
i don't know i don't think personally i
just can't i think a lot of people might
be waiting for the one and i want to
make a mistake i wanna i wanna i wanna
give the gist of that famous uh joke uh
that i've told before
uh there's it's you know you know the
joke about the guy in the flood and he
prays to the lord for
savior
so uh i love this one this one so much
it's good there's a flood a guy's in his
house and he's the the news comes on and
says evacuate now and so he prays dear
lord you know i've been a faithful
servant please save me from this flood
all of a sudden a car pulls up and they
jump out and say quick get in we're
getting out of here both the flood gets
too bad he goes no no i'm not going the
lord will save me and they're like you
have to come with us and he refuses
after a few hours the waters have risen
so high he's reached the second floor of
his house and then once again he prays
oh lord save me i've been a you know
faithful servant and a boat pulls up to
the window and they're like quick get in
we're getting out of here and the guy
says no no the lord will save me the
waters keep rising so he climbs up the
window goes on the roof and then he says
please please lord don't let me die
then a helicopter comes and they're like
they throw a rope down a rope ladder
down quick climb the rope later he goes
no the lord will save me
and then they're like you have to and
helicopter leaves because he won't do it
and the flood waters rise up and he dies
when he makes his way up to heaven he's
you know before god and he says i don't
understand i was i was a faithful
servant that did everything and you let
me die and he goes i sent you a car a
boat and a helicopter but the reason i
tell that joke now is i think for you
ian you're saying you you were single
for so long because you're trying to
find the soulmate perhaps you've already
met them and you just thought it was
going to be something more than it
really was you assumed the soulmate
would come down with wings floating down
before you when it was just some you
know i don't know regular looking person
who was like what up i thought that the
soulmate was gonna make me better but
what i realized was i make myself better
and so she comes she arrives you know
however well the field of dreams
approach mm-hmm if you build it they
would have
you build yourself up i'm curious what
you think of the idea of soul mates as a
psychologist yeah i i don't really
believe in that
so much you know but um but yeah and i i
do think that there's something to be
said you know for as you said just
focusing on yourself and and trying to
attract the right person i think that
our instant gratification society
whether it be you know always the
opportunity to you know swipe right and
you know see more and and constantly
compare it actually makes it harder to
really fix on somebody and you know
settle down on somebody like there have
even been studies that have shown
whether when it comes to like buying
peanut butter for example if you put a
customer in an aisle with 40 different
jars of peanut butter they just won't
buy one like they're just like geez you
know do i want the crunchy or do i want
the organic or do i want that you know
they go on and on and i think the same
thing can happen like with dating that
we just feel like we have too many
choices and it's hard to make one there
there was a i love these studies where
the study is is uh a trick
they had people fill out a survey and in
exchange you get a free t-shirt the
study was actually the t-shirt so these
people thought a form and they and then
with one group they said you get a free
green t-shirt
then with the other group they said you
get your choice between red green or
blue
the the people who after that they were
then asked how they felt about the the
gift the people who were given a choice
were rated it more negatively than those
who weren't the people got a free shirt
were like cool free shirt the people who
got the choice said i made the wrong
choice i should take the blue one so
arranged marriage
you know i have clients that have
arranged marriages believe it or not
it's not work it's it's it's i was i was
surprised to see that it is not like
something that i i thought would never
happen you know but uh my my practice is
in new york and i'm not really seeing
clients as much actively now as i used
to in the past but i mean there's
actually a lot of people from cultures
where their parents are arranging
marriages and it's not as bad as it
sounds like their parents are not like
forcing them to get married to anybody
it's more like their parents are just
like lining up
first dates for them essentially and i
some of some of the clients that i would
have that didn't have that happening for
them they would be like i kind of wish
my parents would do that for me because
it tends to happen obviously not with
all but like in in the jewish
communities and with the um people who
have come from india they they tend to
have that happen more often at least in
just my colloquial observations those
sound like blind dates they're setting
up blind bags basically blind dates yeah
but that's different than saying you're
marrying this person now you're right
it's it's arranged marriage
opportunities you know like where
they're setting up blind dates with
somebody who's marriage-minded but
you're right it's not like they're just
saying hey go meet your husband and also
in most arranged marriages
the person has the option to nominate
it's not like the parent so you have to
marry this person like they pick someone
and then they get to know them and then
if they don't want to they do get the
final say yeah but i think a lot of not
all the time obviously in certain
cultures that's something i think i
think a lot of cultures they can just
say no but then the parents are like
don't do this like we've worked hard at
this culture so there's pressure for
sure
but it used to be with arranged
marriages where like the dad would go to
the dad of the the daughter and be like
how much money do i get we're doing this
salaries dowries and land grants and
things like that that's why a lot of the
royal families were doing it all
well one of the things that i notice in
that conversation about arranged
marriage is that both parties are going
into it with the understanding that they
are dating for marriage is something we
don't have anymore yeah yeah that's a
good point yeah and not only dating for
marriage right but giving up this idea
that there is a quote-unquote soulmate i
think it's a really toxic and
destructive idea that there's going to
be someone who will come along and
you'll just have an effortlessly good
relationship that's not going to be true
about friendships or relationships like
any kind of relationship that you have
and so it makes sense that in our
culture
we would think that because as you
mentioned we're all about instant
gratification so yes of course i'm going
to meet someone who just like bends to
my will and everything which people
don't admit but that's kind of what they
say when they want to soulmate i want i
want someone who isn't going to require
that i change anything about myself or
give anything to and who it's just like
effortlessly pleasurable to be with i
noticed an uptick in video games where
you can get married in the video game
that started like in two thousand
nothing oh dude let's let's let's pull
up this story bro this is a weird stuff
check out the story from guardian
tamagotchi kids could the future of
parenthood be having virtual children in
the metaverse
we're doomed
i don't know i just part of me is like
we can talk about the future and the
dark future and the bright future and we
can be like you know i wonder what
people would experience but i'm telling
you when you get to the point where
you're just not having kids and you're
making robo babies and they're just like
digital video game babies all right
that's it i don't know man yeah a
country that's below the replacement
rate probably does not need this no
there's there's a game coming out called
stray i think it is yeah cat you play as
a cat yeah but all humans are dead
like yeah you have robots right there's
robots everywhere every it's because
like humans built robots and then the
humans died off and now there's robots
living everywhere friends robots
something like that yeah yeah i think
that kind of feels like where we're
going you know uh they're they're
they're building ai that's getting
better and and stronger and faster and
it just really feels like the future is
going to be
ai entities
one of the problems with this and you
brought up sheamus was to make me think
about it is that there's no resist or
maybe not no resistance but the lack of
resistance with digital relationships
video game characters that are your wife
in the game or your child in the game
they don't push back like they don't
come in and tell you what they feel they
don't not really and no one would really
i don't think anyone would want to play
a game where that's the case because you
got real life
um but it's definitely training people
to expect that in real life
i think
people do like video games that offer
them adversity but slightly less
resistance so we play video games for
that dopamine release people will will
take up these tamagotchi babies in the
metaverse and it will be just a easy
enough to where you feel rewarded but
you don't have to do as much work you
don't have to smell it
that's right big part of it well
depending if they plug your brain in
with neural ink you'll smell it all day
what if they made you wake up in the
middle of the night eight times to feed
this thing
to read this thing
i'm not a dad yet
no i'm talking about the robo baby i
have to tell you like waking up to feed
my beautiful babies i mean that's we
were talking about this even before just
i actually said the smell i said but but
but it won't have the smell like i i
need to sniff his hair my little baby
you know i just there's i i i don't
understand like why why people would you
know want this but i mean i one thing
that comes to mind for me also is um
that there's been a a decrease in
people's sense of self right a lot of
people have been coming to therapy you
know saying like that they don't have as
much of a sense of self and a
psychologist have thought about it in
terms of you know the the decline of the
family or decline of religion or you
know social roles kind of you know
breaking down and a lot of people just
don't have what they they feel is like a
a sense of self and so i wonder if on
some level you know these virtual
relationships and you know they're
they're seeking somebody else to to kind
of provide that for them i don't i don't
know but i definitely don't want a
virtual baby i want to smell mine i want
to get a real one see them in the middle
of the night every day just imagine what
it'll be like when
people have like a 16 year old virtual
ai life form and the ai's advance to the
point where it's almost
indistinguishable or completely from a
real person and then
people are like it's a video game so
they don't really care and then this the
ai is begging don't don't leave me mom
no oh my gosh
or or artificial intelligence the
spielberg film hold on check this out
right right what's going to happen is
these ai babies are going to grow up and
then they're going to be 30 years old
and then the millennial cat lady is
going to be like i bought you a body and
they're going to download the a into the
body and it's going to be like i'm a
real boy horrifying a run for office
i think it's funny that yeah what you
think is the scariest part politicians i
mean yes or journalists
i wonder if someone's going to hack it
and then have their digital
20 year old have a digital baby that is
the 20 year old as a baby and they're
gonna be like ah and they're gonna be
like clap look how fun this is to hack
the third hammer
babies are gonna have their own ai
babies and you're gonna have
grandchildren well you're gonna have
like people who don't allow the ai baby
to age
this terrifies me because if the power
goes out not that we can't build
persistent power structure systems like
nuclear batteries and things that can
never go out but if there's some sort of
disruption in the electric flow that
these things disappear it would make an
insanity like it would have a an entire
populace of insanity of people that have
lost their minds their babies basically
and desperate and enraged and this is
there's that show upload where they can
upload your consciousness and in it they
also make ai babies
but there's laws in this in this version
of the future where people who have
their conscious uh consciousness
uploaded can't work
because it would create labor shortages
and stuff because people would never die
and you could do coding and other work
in this digital reality the crazy thing
will be
if we create this alternate virtual
world this metaverse with ai life forms
and then
we start creating interoperability
between virtual world and real world
like
downloaded into a body and stuff then
civilization starts to get starts to get
supplanted by fictional people and
that then you've you've got just
terrifying scenarios where there could
be like ai terror attacks
where like one of these ai babies grows
up and it's like i don't care they treat
us like second-class citizens but i'm
alive and then they hack the grid and
then blow up a real
you know gas plant or something or like
your ai baby just takes your credit card
info and gives it to china yep yep
it's a virus it's literally just a virus
but no i just it's so sad because you
can imagine like a woman in her 50s or
60s who regrets not having a family like
using the the thought of it just makes
me so sad in a way it's someone like
it's like maybe a paraplegic or someone
that lost the use of their legs using a
neural net to regain function
um maybe it could be an opportunity for
people that missed the boat on on having
a baby to experience
but it is a form of psychosis i think
that those people need to go be a good
aunt or uncle to their friends
like this reminds me of like the the sex
dolls thing you know like like the the
real life like realistic sex dolls
things like i don't know i just uh the
whole thing honestly kind of creeps me
out agreed well and so ian you made this
point i think it's interesting you said
what about the people who missed the
boat and they weren't ever able to have
a child
and my response is
the purpose of having a child is not for
you it's not for you to get to have the
experience of raising a child the
purpose of raising a child is to bring a
new life into the world and care for it
and then the whole point of parenthood
is for it to be about the child and not
the parent this totally flips that on
its head that's a good point
tamagotchi kids
crazy oh man in psychology i think sorry
i think it was matt walsh it may have
been maybe jesse kelly i think it was at
wall street said we already have those
they're called cats i believe that was
yeah yeah
it sounds like both of them either one
of them i know they're probably you guys
in the psychology i don't know if it's
industry or whatever but like do you
work with like how ai is impacting human
psychology or how internet and digital
communications are impacting i'm sure
some psychologists do but i i personally
don't um but in terms of psychology i i
will say that to your point sheamus
about uh parenting being about the child
freud and i'm not a big fan of
everything freud ever said or did thank
goodness
one of the things that freud said is
that
women
only really get over their vanity
through motherhood um
so
to your point yeah i mean having become
a mom myself i swear it's like i i've
known many women and men who have said
the same thing it's almost like you feel
your heart growing bigger and bigger and
bigger like you just can't get over how
much you know love and care just pours
out of you is it isn't he the guy who
also said that women wanted dongs
perhaps
that's true that's true they were
envious so that was that yeah i just one
little quote he had that came to mind
that's all
now we're like putting her on trial like
did he not say this as well she was like
no no i wasn't saying it no no i know i
know i know you're the same guy who said
that thing oh yeah he is they had some
interesting he had some other
interesting thoughts on motherhood that
i won't get into yeah i wonder if
another one the mother and the baby have
like a sort of entanglement quantum
entanglement between the two of them
energetically like you said you felt
like you were growing more as a person
as this baby is also growing as a person
and i found with my mom's purely
anecdotal but i stay up late i'm up late
at night and so she
i haven't i went like a year without
talking to her i didn't know she was up
late just turned out that we our our
sleep schedules were in line from across
the country i don't know do you think
that sheamus uh that when when a life is
created part of the souls of the parents
make that soul where does that soul come
from i don't think it's uh from god
that's it so it's interesting because
this is something i sort of got into on
the show it is not like the soul does
not come from the parents it comes from
god that's what the catholic theology do
you think if the soul was like was like
latching on to a piece of matter that
the parents would create a piece of
matter that has a similar latching
structure that a similar soul would
and i'm not sure what you mean i guess
it's supposed that the soul is latching
onto a specific dna structure or a
specific neural you know
geometric pattern in my my brain has a
unique pattern that that soul is
attracted to well it's interesting
because i believe that we're a body soul
composite and you know the soul in the
body are intimately tied together and
i'm not sure exactly how to answer that
question i have to to think about it
but i think just there is i mean i
certainly believe there's a very
beautiful and special relationship
between a mother and child that we can't
really
understand fully with like reference to
other relationships people will try to
sort of analogize the mother-child
relationship to other things especially
in the abortion debate which we've
gotten into a number of times but it's
just like there there's something very
special and unique and different about
that relationship that would almost like
bring harm to it to even try to describe
it's like we can't quite touch it yeah i
get the sense that there's something
there i just don't have any yeah you
know you know what i was thinking let me
let me let me pull this up right here
this other story
would you give up having children to
save the planet meet the couples who
have wow okay well you know i was
thinking it's like it's really funny
that the people who believe the world is
overpopulated are the same people who
believe that you should sterilize your
kids you should not have kids you should
abort your kids you should gorge
yourself until you're on the verge of
death because you can be healthy at any
size and i'm just like
isn't it weird that all of these weird
social things they advocate for just
result in less people
or is it just like
that's what they want well also i'm
gonna be honest and i don't know these
people but when i hear this it generally
strikes me as a post-hoc rationalization
i think people choose not to have
children for lifestyle reasons and then
they'll say something like it's for the
environment because they want to feel
good about themselves i don't think i
don't really know anyone who like really
really wanted to have kids but went i
can't it's for mother earth most people
i know who say that they probably
weren't going to have kids i don't have
many kids anyway i think the issue is
these these young millennial women who
aren't having kids are are femme cells
you know
fem female in cells or whatever i mean i
guess incel works for women as well as
it does for men and i think they justify
it by saying they're they're choosing
this lifestyle it's like sour grapes
it's like well i don't wanna have a kid
anyway it's like maybe it just didn't
work out for you so you're you retreat
to the defensive position of well i
didn't want it so yeah i don't know
because i also know some like attractive
married millennials that are not having
kids like and just have no desire to do
it you know well for sure i'm not saying
that every instance of a woman not
having kids is
wrath
no i think that there are probably many
millennial women who it didn't work out
for and then claim it was yeah
with this not having kids to save the
planet narrative is that you might
choose not to have a kid unfortunately
but you would have been a phenomenal
parent and that kid could have grown up
and made groundbreaking technology that
could have made the world so much better
and then you could be a terrible parent
that has 10 kids or one kid that ends up
being a deviant and a hostile individual
so
it really doesn't matter how many it
matters the quality
how many does matter but not as much as
the quality of what exists yeah but you
if you have like 50 babies you're bound
to have one good one right
odds are i guess it's an interesting
point about the like it's almost like a
rationalization that you're talking
about you know where if suppose that you
you know didn't want to have kids
because you didn't want to um
give up that much of yourself and of
your time and you know then you would
think like okay well does that make me
selfish and then you would invert it by
saying no no i'm not selfish at all i'm
actually doing the world a big favor you
know
i'm just actually you know being so
nurturing here of the world by not
having kids you know so i i don't know i
mean unfortunately i think that that may
be true for some of them but i honestly
think it's unfortunately that there
actually might genuinely be women that
would normally have just wanted to have
kids but they just can get brainwashed
by the idea that you know the world is a
terrible place or you know that the
world cannot support those children and
that makes me really sad so let's take
it to the dark place i suppose if you
advocate for abortion you're less likely
to have offspring if you sterilize your
kids you're less likely to have your
genes persist beyond them if you gorge
yourself and you're very very unhealthy
you're also less likely to have kids
you're going to be
unhealthy and your genes will be removed
from the future future gene pool i went
through from age 28 to 38 to 24 i'm not
having i'm not bringing a kid into this
hellhole this earth that's just falling
apart no no way and it was i started off
saying it almost like a joke and then i
immediately started believing it i
noticed people around me started saying
it and only in the last three or four
years have i regained a will to live in
a kind of a
having faith that
we can make it better as hard as it is
and as dangerous and as destructive as
things can be we can make it better and
so i'm much more open to the idea yeah
no that's a very good point because i
think it says a lot about the state of a
person
based on what they believe it says a lot
less about the world and a lot more
about the person yes i'd given up on
reality yeah
i got way too much information on the
internet in 2006 about
the military-industrial complex monsanto
the pharmaceutical companies all the the
lies the media lies and i was like well
i mean how could we ever dig out of this
we're buried you know for for me i
actually uh
i felt similar that you can't have kids
because the the the climate and
everything was bad until i got on the
internet and started uh diving into the
deep rabbit holes of youtube and then i
realized because the earth is flat and
actually on the back of a turtle all the
climate change stuff doesn't matter
i like titles
i actually i actually begged a doctor to
give me a hysterectomy when i was
younger i've heard a number of people
say similar things i i would love to
hear why you did it i did it because i
was convinced that i never wanted to
have you know children i was just like i
don't want to have to mess with birth
control my whole life like just give me
a hysterectomy and i am so thankful that
the doctor refused so i didn't want a
hysterectomy but i wanted my tubes tied
when i was like 20. and the doctor was
like you are too young and i was like
you're insane i know exactly what i want
what are you talking about and now of
course i'm like oh i'm 30. holy crap i
really like to have kids let's go thank
goodness that that doctor didn't enable
me and now i look at these doctors
giving like you know puberty blockers
because i'm like holy crap i know so bad
it's bad
just like you're too young i was like
yeah you know what i was i had five
siblings and i was like i feel like i've
raised enough kids for my life i'm good
on that one but now i'm like yeah i feel
like it's really important and these
hard times are going to make strong
people well so so what changed for you
you know i mean i was only 17. you know
what i mean so i i think you know what
what changed is i mean my my executive
lobe matured right you know like which
you know doesn't have you're the
executive loop of your brain like which
doesn't finish growing until you're like
25 you know i was also in a very
difficult place in my life i i had a
kind of a crazy childhood and everything
i just don't think i had a good template
in my mind you know for for what that
would look like and then you know just
through maturing and discovering that i
could have good relationships and that
seeing happy families and realizing that
family life could be a lot of fun
it wasn't that big of a leap for me to
be like oh yes motherhood
it's it's wonderful that the doctor was
actually concerned with you in your
long-term interest rather than simply
validating the choice you said you
wanted to make at the time i think it's
very sad that as a society
affirmative care exactly we put so much
emphasis on what a person says that they
want in any particular moment that we
don't even stop to think about their
long-term well-being and also if someone
at 17 says i never ever want to have
children not because i want to do x y z
or i don't think i'm called to marriage
but i just don't want to bring life into
this world i think that's serious cause
for concern for someone to say like hey
what's going on like why do you feel
that way a person is revealing that that
there's as you mentioned some kind of
difficulty there that you were
struggling with and a person should care
when they hear that and want to help
intervene to lift the person not give
them surgeries take a look at this
opening paragraph from this article they
say gwen mckellen was 26 when she
decided to get sterilized
it took the recycling consultant five
years to find the appropriate doctor
under the public health plan she was on
but she was determined you know my only
response is if you are predisposed to
sterilizing yourself well then it's a
self-solving problem for everyone else
right i'm not saying to be mean it's
like if you don't want to have kids your
ideas die with you but here's the thing
i mean even people with bad ideas can
have good children and we are literally
below replacement right now so it's
actually bad for all of us okay seamus
have four kids i think i'm going to
that's one of the best yeah i want i
want look i want to have as many as
possible once i'm married yeah i think
look if
we're i'm talking about i'm like i'm i'm
thinking about
one woman i think i'm married to one so
this is interesting you know what irish
twins are no yes
yes no absolutely i i very much know
what now you know what i heard i want to
double check on this um feel free to
fact check this but i heard that part of
why it it's generally the the stereotype
that irish people have many children
it's not just because you know we're
irish catholics it's because
women are they're less likely to
conceive when they're breastfeeding but
for whatever reason irish women tend to
be more likely to have a mutation where
they still will conceive even while they
are breastfeeding which is why you have
irish twins and irish triplets and irish
babies who are born one after another
so for those that aren't familiar irish
twins is basically when the woman gets
conceives and gets pregnant almost
immediately after she gives birth so you
actually have siblings who are not a
year older than each other yeah i was 13
months younger than my older sister so
my parents were not messing around not
quite irish not quite very close yeah
very close but it's like you'll have two
kids and they're it's like how old are
you i'm 10 and you 10 oh you're twins
well we're 9 months 10 months apart it's
like oh interesting not a year apart are
there is there data explaining why no
well this is this is also why i said
fact this is something i heard recently
that i found interesting and that's why
i'm issuing the caveat to fact check
this i just thought it was a very
interesting theory you know we should do
because it is a phenomenon right like
when people constantly say well when you
breastfeed you will not get pregnant but
i know i actually know a number of like
women who do have irish twins where i
like it's fascinating and that we call
them irish twins i find that really
interesting we should do exponential tax
credits uh child tax credits yeah like
so like the first kid is s x the second
kid is x plus y the third you know third
kid is x plus y squared or whatever the
priceline did that
all right
hungry hungry the problem is having kids
that you don't take care of just for
money because it's not for money it's a
tax credit you're not getting money
you're paying less in taxes but like a
bad parent or one that's vague but like
a parent that's that's vacant that's off
working and has like five kids and they
don't instruct them on what's good and
then the kids grow up and become
villains you know that's a problem i
don't want to encourage that but we're
not giving you money it's a tax credit
so you're keeping more of the money you
earn i just don't know if more is better
it it's the quality of of the unit if
you have more than one child you need
that money you need a tax credit you
need to keep more of the money that you
earn in fact they know that one of the
problems that children face when they're
in a large family is that their parents
aren't able to earn quite as much this
is one of the reasons i wrote about this
this is why dementia is higher in
parents who have more than three
children because it's much more
stressful to be able to work enough to
give for example six children like we're
in my family to be able to give them a
stable home and i still to this day
don't understand how i was a single my
family was a single income home my
mother was a stay-at-home mother and i
had five siblings it's incredible to me
like you cannot duplicate that in this
day and age you guys did a lot of
sustainability right at the house no no
we did have five acres and we had cows
and chickens and goats and stuff but we
weren't like a green family we just um
were like culturally sound we went to
church we followed traditional values we
were homeschooled and my mother stayed
at home it was very interesting
let's go to super chat yes if you have
not already would you kindly smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends become
a member at timcast.com if you want to
support the work we are doing you'll get
access to those exclusive members only
shows we do monday through thursday but
now we're going to read your super chat
so smash that like button get your super
chats in let's see what y'all got to say
all right legoma the gayen says
young democrat male feminists losing
support for feminism is a depressing
reflection of the times the supply chain
issues have made getting rehypnol
difficult for them and suddenly they
want trad wives and gender roles
yikes
yeah maybe
the the mind-altering chemicals courtesy
of china aren't coming in huh
all right
john kersten says tim the whole double
standard and self-censorship idea as you
talk about is herbert marcuse idea of
repressive tolerance
oh yes we uh we talked about that a
little bit before the show you want to
explore yeah yeah so i was uh listening
to the conversations that you guys had a
couple nights ago about um why you know
maybe just saying that there's a double
standard in the press like tim was
saying like i'm just sick of saying it
like can we just stop because we're just
saying it and it's stupid to just keep
saying it and i was saying that in an
abusive relationship it's actually
really important to keep naming and
describing and saying what the abuse is
because otherwise
we actually can go into denial about it
or we can start normalizing it and so
even if we feel powerless to fight it
which tim was um telling me as well that
what he wants is for people to not just
you know quit talking about it but for
people to start doing something about it
which i think is great um but i was
saying like even if you don't feel like
you're ready to do something about it
you should i think not you know quit
talking about it because when we quit
talking about something then we lose
touch with the reality of that thing and
we need to stay focused on it so
actually with my book nervous energy
harness the power of your anxiety the
whole idea there is that you take that
awareness when you sense an injustice
and that something is wrong or you're
having an emotion about it and you use
that emotion to fuel behavior to make a
change so when you're like getting upset
that there's this double standard you
would then say to yourself like okay
well what are five things that i can do
to you know fight this double standard
and tim was talking about his parallel
economy idea which i think is very
intriguing yeah you know so we were
talking and i said what's the point of
telling everyone over and over again
there's a double standard we can all
plainly see and experience and the
solution is what we should be
investing in utilizing alternate
infrastructures alternative
infrastructures so when big tech doesn't
ban antifa but they do ban some random
guys that learn to code we need to start
just saying we get it we're
in an abusive relationship and it's time
to leave so we'll make our own platforms
and that's what's happening that's why
we're using rumble cloud infrastructure
for the website we use rumble for our
members only section and we've got some
other things in the works uh that i that
you know i i frequently mention we can't
talk about until we do it for security
reasons but we've got stuff we're
working on that's really interesting
about speaking up about injustice and
continuing to because in some countries
you'd be killed for speaking up and we
have the first amendment and that's like
a form of exercising that and like a
duty to continue to exercise that right
which is i have to say my next blog is
going to be about the mental health
benefits of free speech so if anybody
wants to get that blog sent to them you
can go to makeachange.us
makeachange.us and give me your email
and i will send you my blog when it
comes out and mental health benefits
free speech we got a super chat here i
am honored it's from joe biden
and it says sheamus hair looks like it
smells good
oh no come on i'll look confirmed well
you know that's all joe huh that's
always different but is there i mean
it's it's not a high compliment is there
anyone who's here he doesn't think looks
like it's smelling well that's a good
point
he'd be smelly let me smell that hair
man come on man what are you doing man
raymond g stanley jr says watched what
is a woman so good yet so sad too
sheamus made a funny joke about uh
about it oh yeah i was like oh ian
mentioned he was watching it before the
show was like but you're not going to
believe the plot twist like when they
find out what a woman is i was like oh
my gosh the twist at the end is amazing
it turns out matt walsh is a woman it
turns out
turns out matt walsh is like i guess i'm
a woman
he was a woman the whole time no problem
that's actually props to him it was it
really was very good the whole movie is
just about his gender transition yeah
he's like just slowly looks more and
more like a woman throughout the film
it's at the end he's like i'm a woman
there are funny bits in there though you
got to see it yeah he's like is my son
my daughter yes i don't want to spoil it
though so it is really good
all right
hola says luke where are you i have
questions about steven banderas and
poland poland and ukraine how connected
are they i.e is it better to be a nazi
just to oppose russia ps what is women
was great
luke i think is going to be here
tomorrow
solid yeah i don't know we're talking
about
good question yep no i don't think it's
better to be a nazi well there's a funny
meme and it says you never ask a man his
seller salary you never ask women her
age and you never ask the ass of telling
what this symbol means and it's the
black sun
[Laughter]
all right
flo says any misogynistic transphobic
speech and coded rhetoric espoused here
will be monitored and recorded you
should learn to tone down your views
believe women trans lives matter we're
building a better world you can't stop
us simply accept it thank you for the 50
good sir
eyes keen
correction shim cast a word can mean
whatever you want it to mean except what
it actually means oh my gosh that's a
very good that's actually very true
joe biden back with another super chat
he says anyone seen my nurse my pony
orange fell off my jupiter chair and the
grilled cheese people attacked the
saloon come on man not the grilled
cheese people the grilled cheese is that
something you said that sounds great i
like no malarkey there no malarkey
what were they thinking with that slogan
no malarkey there was a there was like
he's really old so let's let's roll with
it there was um one
one of the few funny more recent onion
articles was like joe biden appeals to
1930s tough guys with his new slogan no
malarkey
a side of salt says for what is an
assault weapon get in touch with langley
outdoors academy reno may guns and
gadgets and the firearms policy
coalition they'd be great resources
i'm really excited for this one to do
like a deep dive on the history of the
second amendment you do like an intro on
like what the founding fathers actually
expected and what they meant and you can
take a look at i mean there's quotes
from the founding fathers where they're
like the government may become
tyrannical you better give everyone guns
yeah well it's not just guns arms also
include armor
oh yes
yeah armament it included cannons and
privateers and all of that crazy stuff
you know i loved what kerry sheffield
said on your show also a couple days ago
when she talked about how guns for women
actually are the great equalizer
they give us a an extra layer of
protection that helps us a lot there's a
viral video out of brazil
where a guy walks up to a group of women
and tries robbing them and then only
just pulls out her gun that is a
powerful video
you've seen it in broad daylight yeah
there's so many videos from brazil like
that
but yeah man
woman women women don't have to be
worried when they're packing that's
right and the men don't have to be
worried about the women when they're
packing because yeah exactly
i mean you start to be a little worried
you still have to worry for others but
for the most part i worry substantially
less
it's like you're going out stay out of
dark alleys oh you're armed well you
know stay out of them anyway but
don't hang out in the dark alley you're
five yeah
your is good john kirsten says ian was
rare form last night double mopping and
the i i elongated myself adding an inch
and a half had me dying ian
the double mopping thing was oh yeah i
was trying to what time stamp was that
and i wanted to watch that yeah i don't
know i felt like i embodied the double
mopper that's right like really pushing
the mops you know
sure
all right all right that was all tyler
last night it was great that's hilarious
so good
t-craft says due to this wave of
feminism my son 17 years old has stated
that he isn't getting married and saving
the money to have a surrogate to become
a single dad
wow
now kids need moms and dads you know
well look i mean like when you were 17
you wanted a hysterectomy don't assume i
mean
blank that's usually not real
it's true right because how could you
know how could you know well you know in
psychology we have something called the
need fear dilemma which is the thing
that we ought we need the most like
lonely people like they crave
companionship but they also fear it the
most as well like they need fear to
limit the things we need are often the
things we fear yeah i agree strand says
the billboards are a good stick
are good to stick a finger to the elite
news class you need to reach everyday
people they are only reachable via word
of mouth sponsor tim cast in the park
where your show is on a projector for
foot traffic that sounds fun yeah yeah
i'm down how about this anybody who's
watching who wants to put one put on one
of those events
do it let's do it yeah and then you get
one of those those 20-foot projector
screens how much those things cost it's
not like i don't say it's cheap but you
need to put you need a good projector
and a wall of a building
oh yeah you could do that too yeah
i think they can make rules and then so
basically everyone in every jurisdiction
for the summer can do uh oh july is moga
month that's right so how about for maga
month you guys rent up you know space in
a park to do a showing but don't just do
our show maybe do a screening of what is
a woman i just pulled up a 20-foot
projector 220 bucks oh okay not
everybody can afford that but you know
if you're interested that'd be really
really cool and i and i wouldn't want to
just be like promote our show i mean
have our show have other shows maybe do
like an all-day thing where you'll play
like various documentaries films jordan
peterson
this is the big thing
community building
so we're talking about doing skate
competitions blading rollerblading
scooting bike all that stuff so that we
can tell people buy some of this stuff
for your kids get your kids a skateboard
get them rollerblades get them a scooter
bring them on to the park where we're
gonna have burgers and hang out everyone
get to talk community building is so
important yes
all right
king tesseract says so you guys watch
anime occasionally have you watched ttgl
sheamus might like it because it's
basically the gospel of saint simon
peter written by michael bay on lsd it's
an anime version of the gospels fair
warning it was aimed at 14 year old
japanese boys what is ttgl tengen tapa
gurin lagan oh is that it
like name is it really the gospel
simon peter i don't know
curious now
ian kinney says you should have warren
thomas farrell on the show he initially
came to prominence in the 1970s as a
supporter of second wave feminism now
fights for men as it and is the author
of the boy process i am familiar yeah i
watched a video a long time ago where
this guy was trying to go to a um a a a
it's like a lecture on male suicides
and leftists and feminists blocked the
doors and this guy was trying to go and
they wouldn't let him in and they're
like why are you coming here this guy's
a bigot and he's like i want to know why
my friend killed himself and they were
like get out of here you nazi and it was
crazy stuff these people are nuts and
sad stuff
susie anna says after my youngest along
with male classmates were daily forced
to sit legs crossed like a girl and the
female sat with their legs spread like
boys the next semester i pulled my six
boys from public school
you know the funniest thing about the
man spreading stuff was
they were like i just felt like a bunch
of dudes out of themselves having having
small balls or something because i was
like dude i don't like crossing my legs
like that because it hurts my junk
and then there are these guys who are
like just sit with your legs crossed and
i'm like
men sit with their legs crossed with
their ankle on their knee
women sit with their legs crossed with
knee over knee it looks weird to me when
i see a man crossing his legs like a
woman very effeminate yeah i mean i love
doing it every once in a while you get
into that like bohemian artist look
where like they have a cigarette hanging
out of their fingers and they're all
tight and twisted like i just said some
men are outing themselves having small
junk i guess yeah you got to move back
and get your junk lower than your like
below your legs if you're going to twist
and talk
dude
i just think it was really funny that
they did an ad campaign in subways and
billboards being like no man's spreading
and it was just like this idea of man
spreading is not a real thing like
there's videos of women and they're like
cowering as the man's pushing his legs
like he's so oppressed it's like his
man's legs are spread
so that was femme bagging became a thing
yeah women putting their bags on the
chairs yes
i think someone made a video of women
pressing their boobs against a guy and
he got really mad he got mad yeah it was
a gag video was like how dare you boop
smush me
get those things out of here and she's
like i can't like
they're on my chest and he's like yeah
my balls are in my legs
flo says conservatives have for too long
bragged about their socioeconomic
successes
culture and their privilege to defend
their property all at the expense of
black and trans lives it's time that we
democrats change the conversation and
act wow flo thank you for another fifty
dollars yeah
we're more than happy to read all of
those i don't know if that's meant to be
sarcastic or a joke or whatever it's
like very generic but
you know i'll take your money to read it
you do need to change the conversation
not the way change the conversation
all right
what do we got here
colin hinrichs says metoo has taught us
that consent can be revoked once regret
is established keep rocking guys and
gals i got something from basic training
back in 99 i'm going to send y'all cool
sam good says sheamus do you believe
husband and wife are allowed to have sex
for fun
uh well husband and wife should be
having sex with one another i don't
believe that you should do anything
which precludes the possibility of
having a child but it's not as if every
single time people have sex they're
going to be sitting there thinking like
we are making a child right now and
that's our what about pulling out yeah
oh yes we're also against that really
yeah yeah oh wow
like the catholic church is against it
yeah yeah
because it prevents the final end of the
the sexual act right it's for the the
purposes of unity and procreation and so
you're preventing
you're you're getting the pleasure out
of it without fulfilling the purpose
raymond g stanley jr says tim being
called right wing is not a smear yes it
is it's called poisoning the well the
idea is to create a negative
interpretation of what right wing means
accuse your opponents of being that
thing with a buzz term that many on the
right are willing to accept that way
when people are like you know what i
guess i am a conservative you've
poisoned the well on behalf of the
person smearing you then the brainwashed
npc liberals or the default liberals who
hear right wing equals bad see you say i
guess i am and then they go okay you're
bad then
so when they call you right wing they're
doing it to otherize you so it's more
difficult for you to reach regular
people
but for people who are fine with it
you're right you know they don't care
let's say rock raksha jenkins says ian
you are over-bashed and
under-appreciated i appreciate your
unique and likely neurodivergent view on
things i get what it's like when you
perceive weird peripheral connections
between things that others don't yeah i
think of ideas as geometric shapes in a
three-dimensional
sphere that are all kind of fitting into
each other like a rubik's cube so when
people bring up an idea that i don't
understand i still see the shape of it
and how it fits into the conversation
wandering mage says so we all doing maga
month in july right guys serious point
title nine makes dating at college as a
minefield keep in mind that three most
common places people meet their spouses
is school work and church
church july is maga month
dude we are going to be making burgers
and dogs every weekend we better make
some before the show on the forums we
got portillos
i think the best social media dating app
is youtube personally because if you
make videos and you put yourself your
real self out there people see it and
then the people that you would get along
with contact you and you just take it
seriously
i'm really excited for magamoth i can't
do it i can't do it i feel like it's
provoking it's attempting to promote
people what it's the fourth of july bro
i'm celebrating that pennant's day and
that's that's the point but calling it
it's too like republican it's too like
political for me
i i i disagree i think we're gonna we're
gonna change all of our background
photos to american flags yes
it's fourth of july um yeah make america
great man right now absolutely make
america great ian crossland and then
that's magic don't you want an excuse to
just have burgers every weekend
that's all it really is it's like yo
america let's get burger lettuce wrap
yeah if we wrap it in lettuce yeah yeah
we'll do lettuce rip yeah biden's going
to come out uh against mag a month by
making beef so expensive that no one can
celebrate it
yeah we got snacks for the house just
now and it was like 250 bucks
bean burger it was like salamis and
cheese and it was insanely expensive
yeah well i remember a few years ago
we'd go to the grocery store and fill up
the cart for 300 bucks yep then one day
like
last year we went to the supermarket
cart was half full and it was 300
something bucks did you see jamie
diamond he's the
diamond diamond thank you jamie diamonds
he said that storm clouds he said that
people are about to face an economic
hurricane that
is
incomprehensible yeah yeah it's gas
prices dude the diesel shortages forget
the price of diesel when the trucker is
like i'd like to bring the food to your
store but i have no gas but jamie dimon
also said crypto is a joke and then he
bought it and then he bought a bunch
that's what i love when these like these
progressive and these lefties are like
crypto's a scam and i'm like
all of these big banks and institutions
are buying it up
while telling you it's a scam i mean
that says something doesn't it did you
not learn anything from 2008 come on
all right all right let's get some more
super chats in here
okay where are we at
bomb globe says give me your fluids
women
i don't think that's a that's that i
don't think that pickup line is going to
work no it's trade me your favorite
right try it just try that trade with me
trade with you try
john hanson says what are the chances of
getting john stossel on ian check out
rob braxtman internet privacy guy that's
right up your alley uh john stossel is
always welcome on the show he's amazing
he is but he's also very old i don't
know if you can do it somewhat old i
have talked to his people and he's very
busy and also very old that's a deadly
combination he'll love that you guys are
saying that about it yeah yeah but he's
okay yeah he's gonna look good
i've been on his show he had me out oh
he's awesome yeah he's great
to the moon says have you ever had a
baked potato they're pretty sexy it's
pretty great yeah yeah sheamus let's say
you what why is every potato thing have
to be turned back to me the funny thing
is you're the one who started it no i'm
not you guys literally are hey real talk
do you prefer sweet potato or regular oh
regular potatoes i'm a regular potato
man yeah irish propaganda that's right
are you kidding me
bro i'm already sweet or not that's true
yeah
we we had an idea for the vlog for a bit
where it's a background gag where just
like sheamus uses potatoes as currency
so it's not like directly addressed in
the show you just like you'll see him in
the background and the pizza guy will be
at the door while you'll see someone
talking in the foreground in the
background
sheamus will take a piece of the pizza
guy and then hand him a potato but then
the pizza guy will take out two smaller
potatoes as change and give it to him
and take the big potato i only did that
once and they want it to be like a
regular thing it's ridiculous
favorite pizza with potatoes once the
pizza place will be like patty's
pizza it'll be like yes i respect focus
first of all i would never ever pay for
food made by irish people
like are you crazy um
that's not dude shepherd's pie is legit
corned beef man every now and again it's
delicious yeah
i remember when i went to ireland and i
was just like i went to a restaurant and
they were like what'd you be having and
i was like oh come on irish i'm an
american like pine guinness and a
shepherd's pie and i was like yes please
thank you
but then i was informed that i was in
northern ireland so it didn't count no
it didn't
they're like i get to go to dublin and i
was like that is that okay i accept that
i guess
although the people up there didn't you
know they were cool
martin edgar says my daughter said her
mom told her first marriage is for love
the second is for money her mom and i
got married in 1990 and divorced in 96
she's been married four times wow no but
i think that one actually is is a better
saying you know why
the first time
the first time is for love it means you
mean it and at that point if you're
getting married again you're just doing
it because you're trying to exploit yeah
good point yeah but why would you be
getting married again if your first
marriage was for love like why why why
would that marriage end i don't
understand i think because like the
greeks have divided into eight different
types of love and sometimes people feel
one or a few of them but right not it's
not holistic yeah and when you find that
holistic love usually lasts yeah but if
you're going to get married for love the
whole point is like you don't want to
ever have to say goodbye so i don't know
pedro henrique says tim i am a sucker
for your takes i'm a right-wing
libertarian that would love to neighbor
settlements with your socialist compound
thank you for bringing ian some logical
sense and kudos to him to get you
uh west virginia man that's the this is
this is the dream everybody's like texas
and i'm like nah although i think it's
fair to say that those who are moving to
texas and florida are fighting the good
fight yes you're you're changing you
know these are these are texas is
turning purple florida has been purple
and if you move there and you pull back
you're you're helping secure those
locations so i can respect that
moth moniker says could you have elon
musk on tim cast and also thunderfoot
have them on the podcast for a couple
hours now that now is the time for
philip to roast musk in front of the
world have them at the same time
together yeah i wish
thunder foot sure um elon
oh fingers crossed yeah i do want to
mention though we got starlink
so i've been on the waitlist for
starling for like a year
then they launched star of ink starving
star link starve inc star crazy starlink
for rv that's why i said that merged
them on excellent the so the rv version
is instant we got it right away they
shipped it as soon as i ordered it 184
megabits down
five megabits up
82 millisecond latency
we're gonna have to figure out how to
make starlink uh satellites out of meta
materials that are see-through so that
they're more defensible to chinese
attack there's an article so the the
issue is they won't close up the sky
with five megabits up we would not be
able to do the show unless we dropped it
down to like 480
480p and then we'd be streaming i think
like 700k and that would be possible
it's an option if we're on the road and
we want like so pork fest this big
libertarian thing in new hampshire we're
not going to be making it there but we
were considering it the challenge was
how do you get internet in the middle of
nowhere now that we have starlink
we'd be able to do a lower quality
broadcast using starlink so that would
be cool so we can be in the middle of a
desert and do a show that's really cool
yeah so i'm glad we got starlink this is
exactly what i needed it for for the
mobile studio
and uh it's good to have just as an
alternative we could go to the desert on
the van open up the side of the van
flash lights on us sitting in the desert
and record us like with the desert in
the background
yes it would be great yeah i want to do
a show like we could play a live show
like that too it'd be fun yeah
words are power says have y'all heard of
a quote girlfriend experience it's
something that sex workers offer to
mimic a relationship with a person for a
set period of time i think it's terrible
that people are only getting cheap
imitations of the real thing i'm sure it
ain't cheap probably cost a lot of money
yeah but no totally agreed very sad but
you know people the funny thing is you
assume it's going to be like snuggling
and having breakfast when in reality
it's like yelling at you about leaving
your shirt on the floor again
you kicked your shoes off and you threw
your socks on the floor i swear like you
know throughout throughout my house
there are socks just everywhere i
believe it because i'll take my socks
off and just throw them i think there's
like a pair of shoes and socks
underneath the shoes up here i know
that's hilarious no no i was thinking
the exact same thing like wouldn't it be
hilarious it was just like you're
fighting all the time
i looked around my room and there's
clothes laying everywhere i was like i'm
starting to look like tim's house
ian no
you know it was it was funny the other
day i brought up uh so allison is my
girlfriend and she was mountain biking
and so i ate bacon dipped in cheese
sauce for dinner
and then i mentioned that she started
laughing her ass off cause like when
she's around i have like grilled chicken
breast with fresh vegetables and then
when she's not i just dip bacon and
cheese
i'm like that sounds like a really
typical man thing to do it's like well i
can't cook so
you can cook you're great
yeah but i don't have time
and so i'm just
like dipping bacon and cheese is really
good keto
it's keto but it was delicious and i
made the cheese sauce oh okay i made it
the previous night it was uh you know
cause i don't make cheese sauce would
you smell cheese
so cheese cream and then a little
cornstarch to thicken it up and get a
nice you know queso going but there was
a couple different kinds of cheese
garlic it's a little spice in it a
little spicy fresh garlic in there oh
yeah yeah yes i'm getting hungry
it was really good and then the next day
i'm looking in the fridge and there's
like raw chicken breast and i'm like
well i'm not cooking that
you know i don't i don't even know where
to begin and there's like peppers and
vegetables and broccoli and then i just
grabbed the cheese sauce microwaved it
and then we have this pre-packaged bacon
that libby lemon swears by [ __ ] this is
so good and then i just peeled it open
was like dipping it in the cheese i was
i was looking for chips to have just
chips and i didn't have any so i was
like i guess i'll just dip bacon in this
you ever make potato chips that's pretty
fun yeah slice it up fry them up or you
can fry them too yeah and you can bake
tortilla tortilla chips too that's a lot
of fun
all right where were we um
all right nate garland says my wife and
i met and dated in high school and then
got married at 21 both 31 now we're both
sinners saved by grace so we understand
we will fail each other ten years and
three kids later praise god there you go
for you god bless you
islam says language is the culprit
marriage is the real relationship
relationships before marriage are now an
excuse to have sex resulting in perverse
instant
instinction what is it
instant instantiation instantiation love
that word which then has to be resolved
by a divorce sex goggles are real i
believe that having kids is more of a
commitment than marriage
what do you am i off on that but like
there's there's reasons for marriage
that it greatly involves children
yeah no i i hear that i think well i
think people well it's funny because on
the one hand i have met p like i knew
someone who had a kid with someone and i
was like oh when you guys get married
he's like no it's too much of a
commitment i was like you have a child
with it like that what are you talking
about like you have brought a human into
the world with this person yeah so
people yeah but i do believe i do
believe marriage is a very very uh
serious commitment as well people who
need to take it extremely seriously it's
still death it's still death to you part
and you know you're going to be with
that person until that you have to care
like you have a responsibility to your
children right
but you know your children can sort of
move away and go other places like you
are going to be with that spouse forever
if you're doing it right gaming with
spoon says just wanted to say thank you
tim finally caved and watched star trek
because you wouldn't stop talking about
it absolutely loving it keep on fighting
the fight you guys give me hope that we
can get through star trek the next
generation deep space nine yo deep space
nine man
in the pale moonlight the episode where
i'm gonna spoil it because it's just
amazing you got to watch it where they
basically the federation stages a false
flag attack to force one of their
adversaries into a war on their side
brutal
what a great show
next generation is legit all the new
star trek stuff is just like
i'll give i'll i'll try watching the new
one i know what's called what's called
strange new world or something
man
map prequels come on give me an advanced
story come
all right skater own solution says tim
how can we get the timcast boards
previously mentioned want to have them
to give away the contest we are doing
uh send your address
to spin the ufo at gmail.com and we will
have some step on snack and find out
skateboards sent to you and if you would
be so kind title it very clearly what
you're emailing about tell me you're
asking for a step on snake boards uh not
only that here's i'll i'll tell you what
else we'll do if you have a skate shop
and you want some free boards to sell or
give away or do whatever uh send us your
info we we've sent skate shops tim cast
skateboards before we have two graphics
one just says tim cast on it and one
says step on snack and find out
so we'll send you
a lot
i think we sent like 50
to a shop
and it's free like we'll give them to
you for us it's marketing for you you
can sell it make money and support your
shop so i think it's a really really
good idea like the idea that we're gonna
have a bunch of young people with like
boards that rep
you know the show and the website the
skate shops basically are getting a
donation that allows them to make money
to keep going
uh
and not only that the with the boards we
send to you you can sell them for
whatever you want so that means if
you've got kids who are like i can't
afford a board it's no sweat off your
back to be like take this one for free
dude keep skating so that's what we hope
to do that's really i'm really excited
about that
all right let's see
we'll grab one more jill please says i'm
a mother of four i have a good friend
who will never have children due to
mental health reasons she is an aunt to
my children and that is enough for her
well i respect that that's cool
all right everybody if you haven't
already please smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do like
it and head over to timcast.com sign up
to become a member in the top right of
the screen you'll see it help support
our work directly so that we can keep
hiring people we can do more shows we
can make more shows and you can follow
the show at timcast irl on instagram and
basically anywhere else but follow us on
instagram we have clips every day you
can follow me at tim cast dr chloe do
you want to shout anything out yeah make
a change.us
and makeachange.us is where you can get
information on my socials and my blog on
the mental health benefits of free
speech and my book nervous energy
harness the power of your anxiety and my
other book dr chloe's 10 commandments of
dating very cool fantastic sheamus
coughlin
freedomtunes.com ladies and gentlemen we
just launched a membership portion for
five bucks a month you get an extra
animated video every week we're also
going to be uploading behind the scenes
stuff such as tim and i improving some
of the videos we've improved together
really cool stuff uh i really hope you
enjoy it and we're going to start
uploads to that next week there's
already five videos uh five cartoons
there waiting in a bunch of other videos
so thank you very much and have a great
weekend we're about to rap we're not
doing an after show i had a burning
question about your book what's the
simplest way in in a elevator pitch
style to to convert or redirect your
nervous energy
so when you feel yourself feeling
anxious you just ask yourself what could
be the healthy
action that this anxiety is trying to
stimulate me to take because the healthy
function of anxiety is to stimulate
preparation behaviors so when you feel
anxious you say to yourself well what
could i do right now that would help to
improve my current or future situation
but i go into a lot more detail in the
book thank you yes ballmedian
crossover.net if you wanna catch you
later this book sounds awesome i'm
really looking forward to reading it and
i hope that you're willing to leave a
copy or two for us for sure i feel like
anxiety is something that's not
addressed enough it's something left
over from when we're evolving to keep us
on our toes to keep us from being eaten
which is a very useful strategy when
there are saber-tooth tigers around not
so much when we're like living and
working in cubicles and stuff anyway i'm
looking forward to reading it thank you
very much for joining us you guys may
follow me on twitterminds.com it's our
patch list as well as sourpatch let's
stop me
check out
chickencitylive.com if you would like to
watch our chicken city as they do
chicken stuff
and you can like sleep right now and you
can give right right now we have the
chicken lullaby set up so every hundred
dollars in super chats after 8 p.m it
plays a very soothing lullaby for the
chickens we researched this chickens
like classical music so we did brahms
lullaby with strings and everything uh
check it out it's a lot of fun to just
watch but people go there hang out and
chat so they keep the chat going thanks
for hanging out everybody we will be
back next week we'll see y'all then
you